Well, I know your camera's tilted a little down and I'm noticing your legs. You're wearing some shorts today. Thank you. By the way, Fritzvall, let me just say thank you. 40 degrees outside. Thank you so much. I appreciate the compliment. Why do you wear shorts?
我知道你的摄像头稍微向下倾斜，我注意到你的腿了。你今天穿着短裤。谢谢。顺便说一句，弗里茨瓦尔，请允许我向你道谢。外面40度。太谢谢你了。我很感激你的夸奖。你为什么穿短裤？
Have you not been outside the house to do drop off at all today? Thanks again. I just want to say for me, it's hard to take so much credit. Obviously, the man upstairs sculpted these babies, but... Wait, you live in a duplex? Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha That looks badass. Doesn't that look good? You can't hear this yet. Damn.
你今天出门接送孩子都没去过室外吗？再次谢谢你。我只想说，对我来说，揽下这么多功劳挺难的。显然，楼上的那位上帝雕刻了这些宝贝，但是……等等，你住在复式公寓里？看起来太帅了。是不是看起来很棒？你现在还听不到这个。该死。
And we have Will Audio, Shawnee Joining, Shawnee Joining. Really? I think that looks fucking badass. Do you? Yeah, I didn't go with that. I think it looks great. We are rolling, surprise the guests, give us a little clap if you don't mind.
我们有Will Audio，肖尼加盟，肖尼加盟。真的吗？我觉得这看起来他妈的太酷了。是吗？对，我没选那个。我觉得看起来棒极了。我们在录制了，给嘉宾一个惊喜，如果不介意的话，给我们鼓个掌吧。
All right, we're rolling. Jewelry, have fun. I might do it, I was doing a little test for this new thing I'm doing, and I might do it. I might do it, I might keep it, I don't know. I think that's the winner right there. Yeah. Jesus. It's all about-
好了，我们在录音了。珠宝，玩得开心。我可能会用，我刚才在为我正在做的新东西做个小测试，我可能会用。我可能会用，我可能会保留它，我不知道。我觉得那个就是赢家。对。天哪。这全关乎——
It's a fucking bone structure. How do you get fucking bone structure with a haircut? Yeah. I don't know, man. I guess it's just, hang on, I looked it up before. Genetics. Genetics. Genetics.
这他妈是骨骼结构。你怎么通过剪个头发弄出他妈的骨骼结构？对。我不知道，老兄。我猜这只是，等一下，我之前查过。基因。基因。基因。
Sorry. That's really good. Fucking great. Really good. I love seeing you, JB, in the full vest, in the down vest this morning. It's coming off the slopes. Oh, no, I just, this is just a carpool drop-off,
抱歉。这真的很棒。非常棒。真的很棒。我很高兴看到你，JB，今天早上穿着全套羽绒背心。刚从雪道滑下来。哦，不，我只是，这只是拼车接送，
whatever you call it, school drop-off. What are these kids, what are my kids' names? Yeah, I know. What's a young one? Tell me the young one's name. Maple's the name. That's Maple. That's your drop-off.
随便你怎么称叫它，学校接送。这些孩子是，我的孩子们叫什么名字？对，我知道。小家伙叫什么？告诉我小家伙的名字。名字叫梅普尔。那是梅普尔。那是你的接送。
Fresh back from drop off. Yeah. This is post drop off pre shower, pre G4, handsome golf outfit. Oh, so you do have golf today. So you're going to take a shower before? I will be taking a shower. Yes. Getting it all nice and powder dry. Clean.
刚接送完回来。对。这是接送后、洗澡前、G4前、帅气的打高尔夫球的行头。哦，所以你今天确实要去打高尔夫。那你之前要洗个澡吗？我会洗个澡的。是的。把它弄得干干净净、清清爽爽。
You know our buddy Skip Bronson. Skip Bronson saw him yesterday swinging it over there. He claimed that we're the visor twins. Cause you and I. I do like a visor. Yeah. I like a visor cause I feel like this big dumb head of crazy hair can't fit into a cap nowadays.
你知道我们的好朋友斯普·布朗森（Skip Bronson）。斯普·布朗森昨天看到他在那边挥杆。他声称我们俩是遮阳帽双胞胎。因为你和我。我确实喜欢戴遮阳帽。对。我喜欢遮阳帽，因为我觉得我这个装满疯狂头发的大笨脑袋现在根本戴不下鸭舌帽了。
I like your new look by the way. We were talking about it, Jay. Your new look is sort of rugged. They were both trying on some new looks for parts coming on. I'm supposed to be looking like a ex-drummer, drug addict, loser, and I'm really kind of nailing it with this stupid long hair and facial hair. I look like I'm playing a hooligan, like a soccer hooligan.
顺便说一句，我很喜欢你的新造型。我们刚才还在讨论呢，杰伊。你的新造型有点粗犷。他们俩都在为即将出演的角色尝试新造型。我本来应该看起来像个前鼓手、瘾君子、失败者，而我顶着这头愚蠢的长头发和面部毛发，真的把这个造型拿捏到位了。我看起来像是在扮演一个暴徒，就像一个足球流氓。
Yeah, yeah. You know what I mean? What do I look like I'm playing? Now, careful, well, be nice, well. Like a 53-year-old Illinois house husband. Yeah, it's a family after school special about a 50-year-old that's going back to elementary school because he just didn't get fifth grade right.
对，对。你知道我的意思吗？我看起来像在演什么？现在，小心点，威尔，放尊重点，威尔。看起来像个53岁的伊利诺伊州家庭主夫。对，这是一部关于一个50岁的人重返小学的课后家庭特别节目，因为他当年五年级没学好。
And body swaps. There's going to be a body swap, right? Well, there's going to be a lot of body swap. JB's done a body swap. He's got a lunch pail. Yeah, I did a body swap movie. Yeah. Me and Ryan Reynolds pissed into a magic fountain
还要互换身体。会有身体互换的桥段吧？好吧，会有很多身体互换。JB演过身体互换。他提着一个午餐盒。对，我拍过一部身体互换电影。对。我和瑞安·雷诺兹往一个魔法喷泉里撒尿，
and you know what happens. And then you decided to do a movie together? What happened? Oh, well, this guy, he's really on me today. He's getting me, huh? Shawna, you got some texts coming through, Shawna, you wanna just take care of them? I'm trying to find the photo of my shaved head.
你知道接下来会发生什么。然后你们决定一起拍部电影？发生了什么？哦，好吧，这家伙，他今天真的缠上我了。他抓住我了，是吧？肖娜，你有些短信发进来了，肖娜，你想不想处理一下？我正在找我剃光头的照片。
I can't find it. Are you advertising for Brentwood Country Mart? What is that? What are you just saying? This is where I like to find it. Are you advertising for Brentwood Country Mart? What is that? What are you just saying? This is where I like to eat most. Hey, welcome back to hashtag relatable. This week we're going over markets. Anybody can go to the Brentwood Country Mart.
我找不到它。你是在为布伦特wood乡村集市打广告吗？那是什么？你刚才在说什么？这是我喜欢找的地方。你是在为布伦特wood乡村集市打广告吗？那是什么？你刚才在说什么？这是我最喜欢吃东西的地方。嘿，欢迎回到“#极具共鸣”。本周我们要聊聊市场。任何人都可以去布伦特wood乡村集市。
It's fantastic. Is that their tagline? It's fantastic. Boy, they didn't put a lot of thought into that. It's terrific. It's dynamite. It is very good. I do want to speak about dynamite. It is very good. All right, Will.
太棒了。那是他们的标语吗？太棒了。天哪，他们没花多少心思在这上面。太绝了。太带劲了。确实很不错。我确实想谈谈“带劲”。确实很不错。好吧，威尔。
I do want to speak about dynamite. I want to speak about dynamite because this, our guest today is nothing. Is dynamite? Well, nothing short of dynamite. Let me just say that much and I'll tell you why. She's explosive. We do know it's a she, I heard a giggle
我确实想谈谈“带劲”。我想谈谈“带劲”，因为这个，我们今天的嘉宾简直无。是带劲吗？好吧，简直就是带劲。我只能说这么多了，我会告诉你为什么。她很有爆发力。我们知道这是个女的，我听到了一声咯咯的笑声，
and I heard some jewelry on the clap. Oh, you did? Yeah, I heard a gig. Yep. You heard a gig too. Where is everybody hearing all these gigs? Yeah, I heard a gig. Yep. You heard a gig too. Where's everybody hearing all these gigs? Well, we've got actual headphones on. You've got snazzy earbuds. I don't know, man. I just, I don't know how I missed the gig anyway. I, um, this is something.
我还听到鼓掌时首饰发出的声音。哦，你听到了？对，我听到了一声咯咯笑。没错。你也听到咯咯笑了。为什么每个人都听到这些咯咯笑声？对，我听到咯咯笑。没错。你也听到咯咯笑了。为什么每个人都听到这些咯咯笑声？好吧，我们戴着真正的耳机。你戴着时髦的无线耳机。我不知道，老兄。我只是，我不知道我怎么会错过那个咯咯笑声。我，呃，这可真有意思。
Oh man, this is so good. Yeah, take your time. Well, I was just going to say, so we get a lot of, we get, we get, we get, oh, there. Oh, look at just gonna say so we get a lot of She is ready. She's a singer. I tell you why she's ready because this is somebody who's got you know, we've had we've had award-winning Actors and actresses and performers and directors But imagine being nominated for four Academy Awards and winning one imagine it imagine being nominated for two BAFTAs and winning one Imagine being nominated for god damn it. I get winning one. Imagine being nominated for me for Golden Globes five SAG awards. Yeah. Are you starting to get what I'm throwing down you guys? Yeah, you're starting to get that. Because this person has done some of the greatest biggest films
哦天哪，太棒了。好的，慢慢来。嗯，我正要说，所以我们有很多，我们有，我们有，我们有，哦，在那儿。哦，看，我正要说所以我们有很多她准备好了。她是个歌手。我告诉你为什么她准备好了，因为这是一个拥有，你知道的，我们曾有过，我们曾有过获奖的演员、女演员、表演者和导演，但想象一下获得四次奥斯卡奖提名并赢得一座，想象一下，想象一下获得两次英国电影学院奖提名并赢得一座，想象一下获得，天哪。我得说赢得一座。想象一下获得，我获得了金球奖，五个美国演员工会奖。对。你们开始明白我的意思了吗，伙计们？对，你们开始明白了。因为这个人曾经拍过一些史上最伟大、最大的电影，
of all time. Some of the most cool independent films, thought provoking films. She's done it all. She is somebody that I have admired for a long time, me and the rest of the world. I don't know how else to say other than to say, guys, it's Penelope Cruz. Oh, wow.
一些最酷的独立电影、发人深省的电影。她都拍过。她是我一直以来非常钦佩的人，我和全世界的其他所有人一样。除了说出她的名字，我不知道还能怎么介绍，伙计们，她就是佩内洛普·克鲁兹。哦，哇。
Can you believe it? I mean, this is... What is that? It's a royal tea on the market. It's a royal tea. Look at her go. Penelope. Hi. Oh, look at her go. Hail royalty. Hi.
你们能相信吗？我是说，这真是……那是什么？这是市场的皇家礼遇。这是一场皇室礼遇。看她走过来。佩内洛普。嗨。哦，看她走过来。向皇室致敬。嗨。
Hi. What an amazing presentation. I don't think I deserve that, but thank you so much. Oh my gosh, it's absolutely true. Hello. Well, all of it's true. Nice to meet you. Good morning.
嗨。多么精彩的介绍。我觉得我受之有愧，但非常感谢你们。哦天哪，这绝对是真的。你好。嗯，全都是真的。很高兴见到你们。早上好。
Nice to meet you too. Nice to meet you. Thank you for joining us. Where do we, we're not in your bedroom, we're in a hotel room. Are we not? Where are we? This is actually not my bedroom, we're in a hotel room, are we not? Where are we? This is actually not my bedroom.
我也很高兴见到你们。很高兴见到你们。谢谢你们邀请我们。我们在哪儿，我们不是在你的卧室里，我们在一个酒店房间里。难道不是吗？我们在哪儿？这其实不是我的卧室，我们在一个酒店房间里，难道不是吗？我们在哪儿？这其实不是我的卧室。
That this is a room where they brought me to do the interview. Where are you, you're doing some press? We are in a hotel for a couple of days here in LA. Yeah. And going back home soon. She's doing, Penelope, and correct me if I'm wrong, you're here doing press for a Ferrari,
这是他们带我来做采访的房间。你在哪儿，你是在做宣传吗？我们在洛杉矶的一家酒店待几天。对。不久就要回国了。佩内洛普，如果我没记错的话，你来这里是为《法拉利》做宣传的，
your new film that you've done with Michael Mann, is that true? Yes, yes, true. Which is fantastic, and we had the pleasure of meeting one of your co-stars, Adam Driver, and we're very excited for Ferrari. Yeah, I can't wait to see it. But I'm really excited to talk to you, Penelope,
这是你和迈克尔·曼合作的新电影，对吗？是的，是的，没错。这部电影棒极了，我们有幸见到了你的联合主演亚当·德赖弗，我们对《法拉利》感到非常兴奋。对，我迫不及待想看了。但我真的很想跟你聊聊，佩内洛普，
about just what an incredibly diverse career that you've had, that you've carved out. And I kind of want to touch on something, I'm so excited you're here by the way. I want to talk about- I mean too, I think this is wild. There's a story that I picked up on. I saw an interview you did with Terry Gross on Fresh Air
关于你那不可思议的、丰富多样的职业生涯。我想顺便提一件事，顺便说一句，我很高兴你能来。我想聊聊——我也是，我觉得这太疯狂了。我偶然听到一个故事。我看到你接受特里·格罗斯（Terry Gross）在《清新空气》（Fresh Air）节目中的采访，
and it really piqued my interest. And guys, I don't know if you know this. And I'd love for you to speak to this. You talk about, you were a big fan of Pedro Almotivar, right? Fantastic fan, the great Spanish filmmaker. And you would tell your friends, you were putting yourself in a position to see him. You're not necessarily waiting outside his house,
真的引起了我的极大兴趣。伙计们，我不知道你们知不知道这件事。我很希望你能谈谈这个。你谈到过，你曾是佩德罗·阿尔莫多瓦的超级粉丝，对吧？狂热的粉丝，伟大的西班牙电影制作人。你会告诉你的朋友们，你把自己置于能见到他的位置。你倒不一定是在他家门外等候，
but you would go to restaurants. Also, also I did. But you did wait outside his house. That's something I would go. Yeah, a couple of times. Yeah, like a cycle. A couple of times, and then would go to bars and restaurants and wait, and your friends But you did wait outside his house. That's something I would go. He had a couple of times. Yeah, me too. A couple of times and then would go to bars and restaurants and wait and your friends thought you were insane
但你会去餐厅。而且，而且我确实去过。但你确实在他家门外等过。那是我会去的地方。对，好几次。对，就像一个狂热粉丝。好几次，然后会去酒吧和餐厅等候，而你的朋友们——但你确实在他家门外等过。那是我会去的地方。他去过好几次。对，我也是。好几次，然后会去酒吧和餐厅等候，而你的朋友们觉得你疯了，
and you said, believe me, I have this connection and it will happen. Can you talk to us a little bit about that blue one? Yes, what is that? I know for a lot of people it can sound weird and also it sounded crazy to him when I told him for the first few years he didn't believe me. And then a lot of things like that started to happen between him and I.
而你说，相信我，我跟这个人有某种联系，这一定会发生。你能跟我们聊聊那个蓝色的吗？是的，那是什么？我知道对很多人来说这听起来很诡异，而且他刚开始听到时也觉得很疯狂，头几年他根本不相信我。然后很多类似的事情开始在我和他之间发生。
And I think by now, like 30 years later, he believes me. We have a very special connection and I was a huge fan of his work. You know, I didn't have a theater, a cinema near where we lived, because we lived outside Madrid and I developed love for movies and different actresses and directors through the Betamax machine that my father and my mother bought when I was like a kid. You remember how heavy and big the Betamax was. So I asked them to give me a copy of the cards for the video store.
我想现在，大约30年后，他相信我了。我们有着非常特殊的联系，我是他作品的超级粉丝。你知道的，我们住的地方附近没有剧院、电影院，因为我们住在马德里郊外，我是通过我爸爸妈妈在我还是个孩子时买的Betamax录像机，培养出了对电影以及不同女演员和导演的热爱。你还记得Betamax录像机有多笨重吗？所以我让他们把录像厅会员卡的复印件给我。
And I was there every afternoon after school and after my homework and my dance classes. What I wanted to do is be alone and watch a movie. If I liked a movie, I would watch it 20 times in a row. Like really study that film. And that's how I discovered Pedro and Spielberg and Scorsese and Billy Wilder and... So what were you filming those movies
我每天下午放学、做完作业和上完舞蹈课后都会去那里。我只想一个人待着看部电影。如果我喜欢一部电影，我会连续看20遍。就像真的在研究那部电影一样。这就是我发现佩德罗、斯皮尔伯格、马丁·斯科塞斯、比利·怀尔德的方式……那么你当时在拍那些电影吗？
that you would watch 20 times? Like that you love, love, love as a kid? I mean, I always knew I wanted to act, but I had no, apart from the couple of hours that I spent doing classical ballet, that was like very hardcore, but at the same time it was a way of acting, and a way to release that need that I had of
你会连看20遍？就像你小时候超级超级超级喜欢的那些？我的意思是，我一直都知道我想演戏，但我除了花几个小时跳古典芭蕾——那非常高强度，但同时也是一种表演方式，是一种释放我内心渴望的方式，
visiting and investigating different ways of being and different realities And I think I would have been very damaged if I didn't have that but then I discovered that that was like a window to the world, you know, like I could dream about a that was like a window to the world. You know, like I could dream about a what that life would be like or this or that and put yourself in somebody else's shoes. And I felt like this is what I want to do in my life.
去体验和探索不同的生活方式和不同的现实。我想如果我没有接触到这些，我可能会受到很大的创伤，但我后来发现那是一扇通往世界的窗户，你知道的，我可以梦想着那种生活会是什么样，或是这种、那种生活，去设身处地为别人着想。我觉得这就是我一生想做的事。
I don't know how. I didn't know anybody related to the business, anybody that could make a living out of something related to arts. When I said that to my parents, it was like saying I want to be an astronaut. It was very surreal for them. I just appreciate that they didn't invalidate me.
我不知道怎么做。我不认识任何与这个行业相关的人，也不认识任何能靠艺术相关行业谋生的人。当我把这个想法告诉父母时，感觉就像说我想成为一名宇航员。对他们来说太超现实了。我很感激他们没有否定我。
They didn't laugh. They said, you can try if that's what you want. We'll pay your dance classes and then your theater classes, but have a plan B because probably this won't work. So through that Betamax machine, I started planning. But I mean, imagine that, I mean, you say that, right. It's like saying to your parents, I wanna go live on the moon.
他们没有嘲笑我。他们说，如果你真的想要，你可以去尝试。我们会付你的舞蹈课费用，然后是戏剧课费用，但一定要有B计划，因为这可能行不通。所以通过那台Betamax录像机，我开始做计划了。但是，想象一下，我是说，你这么说，对吧。这就像对你的父母说，我想去月球生活。
You grew up in a small town outside of Madrid. You don't even have a theater. And all your connection to films is through renting Betamax. Yes. And then you, but you have this dream All your connection to films is through Rending Betamax films. Yes. Yes. But you have this dream, and lots of people have dreams that they,
你在马德里郊外的一个小镇长大。你甚至连个剧院都没有。你和电影所有的联系就是通过租Betamax录像带。是的。然后你，但你有这个梦想——你和电影所有的联系就是通过租Betamax录像带。是的。是的。但你也有这个梦想，很多人都有梦想，
I wanna do this, I wanna do that. But the follow through is so precise to the point that you're like, you identify, well, Sean had asked like, what were the films that really inspired you? And I do wanna get that, but you identify specifically as you get older
我想做这个，我想做那个。但你的执行力是如此精准，以至于你会去确定，好吧，就像肖恩刚才问的，到底是什么电影真正启发了你？我确实想知道这个，但你特别明确地随着年龄增长，
that you know that you want to connect to Pedro. Yes. And that you're like, the follow through, and like you said, for some people it might seem weird, but you knew that there was something there. You thought you were pretty confident that like, once he meets me, I know we're gonna have a connection.
你知道你想跟佩德罗建立联系。是的。而且你的执行力，就像你说的，对某些人来说可能显得很诡异，但你知道那里有些东西。你相当自信，只要他见到我，我知道我们会有所联系。
He seems like the kind of guy I would get along with. And you just courted And you just put yourself in front of him? Yeah, not because I thought I was good, just because I thought that he saw the world in a very similar way to the way that I saw it since I was a little girl. And actually, I got into one of the sets without permission when I was 14 and he was doing... No, when I was like 15, 16, he was doing high heels and he was shooting with Victoria Abril, one of my favorite actresses. And I just walked in, nobody stopped me.
他看起来像是那种我能合得来的人。然后你主动去结交——然后你把自己送到他面前？对，不是因为我觉得自己有多好，只是因为我觉得他看待世界的方式，跟我自小看世界的方式非常相似。事实上，我14岁时就无权限闯入过其中一个片场，当时他正在拍……不，大概我15、16岁时，他正在拍《捆着你，绑着我》（High Heels），跟我的最爱之一维多利亚·阿布里尔（Victoria Abril）合作。我就这么走了进去，没有人拦我。
I sat very close to the monitor, nobody said anything. And he looked at me and I said, oh my God, he's gonna say something. He just looked at me for a few seconds, like, do I know you? We know each other. That was enough for me for that day to be able to spy and be there for a couple of hours. But then when, because he was the one,
我坐在离监视器非常近的地方，没有人说什么。他看着我，我想，天哪，他要说什么了。他只是看着我几秒钟，好像在想，我认识你吗？我们认识吗？对我来说，那天能去偷窥并在那里待上几个小时，这就足够了。但后来，因为他是那个人，
like you said before, such a specific dream, he was the one that I wanted to meet, to thank, and to be able to maybe one day work with him. So when I did my first two movies, I got that phone call. My two first movies were very different from each other, Bellapok and Hamon Hamon, and I was very lucky to have that presentation card, because the characters were like day and night,
就像你刚才说的，这是一个如此具体的梦想，他是我想要去见、去感谢，并希望有一天能跟他合作的人。所以当我拍完前两部电影时，我接到了那个电话。我的前两部电影截然不同，《四千金的情人》（Belle Époque）和《火腿火腿》（Jamón Jamón），我很幸运能有这份名片，因为两个角色有着天壤之别，
and that was important to come to start that way. And somebody said to me, Almodóvar is on the phone. And I was drawing my hair, preparing for classes. And I said, yeah, right. Almodóvar is on the phone. And it took me like five minutes to react because I thought, how can in,
以这种方式开局非常重要。有人对我说，阿尔莫多瓦在电话里。我当时正吹着头发，准备去上课。我说，得了吧。阿尔莫多瓦在电话里。我花了大约五分钟才反应过来，因为我在想，怎么可能，
is it for real that dreams so specific can become a reality and he was there and his voice was like, oh, this old friend that I haven't seen for a long time and the connection was instant. I lied to him about my age. We did the casting for the movie. It was not appropriate for my age, the movie.
这么具体的梦想竟然能变成现实，这难道是真的吗？他就在那里，他的声音听起来就像，哦，这是一个我很久没见的老朋友，那种联系是瞬间建立的。我为了年龄对他撒了谎。我们为那部电影试镜了。那部电影不适合我的年龄。
So the casting was just a conversation about like, really how old are you? I know you were lying to me. So I said, yeah, actually, yes, I'm like at that point, I think 18, he said this character has to be at least 25 or 30, but I will write a character for you in my next film and he did. Jesus, and this is,
所以试镜只是一场关于“你到底多大？我知道你在对我撒谎”的对话。所以我说，好吧，其实，是的，我当时大概18岁吧，他说这个角色至少得25或30岁，但我会在下一部电影里为你量身打造一个角色，他真的做到了。天哪，这简直是——
imagine getting that call, Sean it would be like you if they, if they're like, Sean, Kraft McGroney and cheese is on the phone. And you'd be like, I had like dreams come true. Kraft McGroney and cheese is not on the phone. Like if you have a specific chain, you can come.
想象一下接到那个电话，肖恩，这就好比如果他们，如果他们说，肖恩，卡夫麦汁通心粉在电话里。你会觉得，我的梦想成真了。卡夫麦汁通心粉才不在电话里。就像如果你有特定的追求，你就能实现。
He loves food. Penelope. Me too. But. So Penelope, what about when you filled him in on this story about that you've been following him around? Did he, was he charmed by that? Did he laugh?
他热爱食物。佩内洛普。我也是。但是。那么，佩内洛普，当你把跟踪他的这段经历告诉他时，他是什么反应？他觉得这很有趣吗？他笑了吗？
Did he remember you being at the monitor when you were 15? No, not that, but then I told him, look, one time at the cinema, I told my friends that I was gonna find you that day. And it was just a random cinema by the time that I was able to go to the cinema alone when I was older. And my friend couldn't believe it
他还记得你15岁时坐在监视器旁的事吗？不，不是那个，但后来我告诉他，听着，有一次在电影院，我告诉我的朋友我那天一定要找到你。那只是一个普通的电影院，那时我长大了点，可以独自去看电影了。我的朋友根本不敢相信，
because by the end of the movie, we came out and he was there in the street. And a lot of things like that. At the beginning, he was looking at me like, yeah, right. Okay, you are very young and you are believing all. But now he does. You can ask him and now he does. Like these things happen between him and I.
因为电影散场时，我们一出来，他就在街上。很多类似的事情都是这样。一开始，他看着我的眼神就像是：得了吧。好吧，你年纪轻轻，竟然信了这些。但现在他信了。你可以去问他，他现在信了。类似的事情就这么发生在我和他之间。
That's cool. So how many films have you done with him now? Seven. Seven. And I hope many more. I just talked to him this morning. Wow, that's amazing. He's one of the greatest. He's one of the loves of my life. He's much more than a director I work with. He's family. Sure, of course.
太酷了。那你现在拍了他多少部电影了？七部。七部。我希望还会有更多。我今天早上刚跟他通过话。哇，太惊人了。他是最伟大的导演之一。他是我生命中的挚爱之一。他远不止是一个跟我合作过的导演。他是家人。当然，肯定的。
And he is hilarious. And you have to invite him here because he will make you laugh so much. It would be like a dream come true. He's one of the great directors and he's one of the great imaginations, one of the great storytellers. And then the guys know I don't use that term lightly. Wow. But before you worked with him, you had done two films, right? Before you worked with Pedro.
而且他极其搞笑。你必须邀请他来这儿，因为他会把你逗得前仰后合。那简直就像美梦成真。他是最伟大的导演之一，拥有最伟大的想象力、最伟大的故事讲述能力之一。伙计们知道我不会轻易用这个词。哇。但在你跟他合作之前，你拍过两部电影，对吧？在你跟佩德罗合作之前。
What was it like at that point? What were the opportunities like in Spain for you at that point in the Spanish film industry. Was there a lot going on? Was it robust? Was it difficult? It was like a miracle that I found my agent. When I found my agent, she's now 83,
那时情况是怎样的？当时西班牙的电影行业对你来说有哪些机会？当时有很多片约吗？发展强劲吗？还是举步维艰？我找到经纪人就像是个奇迹。我找到她时，她现在已经83岁了，
and we've been together since I was 14, 15. The first time I went to see her, she sent me home. She said, what are you doing here? You're too young. Please go away. I came back the week after. She said the same thing to me. I came back the week after. And then I asked her to let me do an improv, where I could just play somebody that was very angry. And in my improv, I was actually an actress
我们从我14、15岁起就一直在一起。我第一次去找她时，她把我轰回家了。她说，你来这里干什么？你太小了。请走吧。一周后我又去了。她对我说了一样的话。一周后我又去了。然后我请求她让我即兴表演一段，扮演一个非常愤怒的人。在即兴表演中，我实际上是一个女演员，
that was talking about her dreams. I was asking for an opportunity, even if I was young. And then I was the only person that she picked that year to be represented and out of 300 people. And we're still together, you know? And I love her so much. She started to send me to castings and to my surprise. I got a yes as an answer.
在倾诉自己的梦想。我在为自己争取一个机会，尽管我还年轻。然后我是她那一年在300个人中唯一挑选签约的人。我们到现在还在一起，你知道吗？我太爱她了。她开始送我去试镜，令我惊讶的是，
I could not believe it. I mean, it got a yes as an answer. I could not believe it. I mean, it was a big surprise to me. Penelope, all the dreams that you had about, I hope it happens. I wanna meet Pedro, I want my career to take off. I wanted all the dreams you had, all the aspirations that you had. You now, I would assume, have them even bigger
我得到了肯定的答复。我简直不敢相信。我是说，我得到了肯定的答复。我简直不敢相信。这对我来说是个巨大的惊喜。佩内洛普，你曾有过的所有梦想——我希望这一切能实现，我想见佩德罗，我想让我的职业生涯起飞——你所有的梦想，你所有的抱负，现在我想象它们甚至比你当年梦想的还要宏大。
than you even dreamed back then. Is it what you thought it would be? Do you tell... What's your favorite part about what has become and what part of it did you not anticipate coming and you could kind of do without? That part is... I didn't think it would be bad like that. What's your favorite part? What's your least favorite part? My favorite part about this profession and the one that gives me a real happiness that can last and that is based on hard work
这和你想象的一样吗？你会告诉……对于这一切的演变，你最喜欢的部分是什么？其中有什么是你始料未及的、觉得没有也罢的？那部分是……我没觉得会有这么糟。你最喜欢的部分是什么？你最不喜欢的部分是什么？我最喜欢这个职业的，也是能给我带来持久的、基于努力工作的真正快乐的部分，
and the values that I think my parents taught me is the part that you are new each time you are starting from zero. You never get to a place where you feel you have things under control. You are like a constant student. You're never gonna do the same role twice or maybe you will but that's a different story. But you are gonna be challenged each time and have fear each time. And I feel like we could have this conversation when I'm 90 and I would still feel the same way. And I feel that's good for me, it's good for my mental health. It keeps me sane, it keeps me humble because it's about the learning process, it's about how we really are just one more piece of the puzzle when we are on the set
以及我认为父母教给我的价值观，就是每一次你都是全新的，你都是从零开始。你永远不会到达一个觉得一切尽在掌握的地方。你就像一个永远的学生。你永远不会演两次相同的角色——也许会，但那是另一回事。但你每一次都会面临挑战，每一次都会感到恐惧。我觉得就算我90岁了，我们进行这样的对话，我依然会有这种感觉。我觉得这对我有好处，对我的心理健康有好处。它让我保持清醒，让我保持谦逊，因为这关乎学习的过程，关乎我们身处片场时，其实不过是拼图中的又一块罢了。
We cannot do this this work alone and this is Amazing about me my about my profession and I realized is what attracted me to it from day one The thing that I was surprised is that there was the element of attraction to fame when I was a teenager. I thought like, wow, like really? Me? They are saying this or that. But still, you get kind of a dopamine high from it, especially if you are very young, but that doesn't last. That goes away. And if you are evolving in a good way and you have a family around you that is going to be telling you the truth and cutting all the bullshit, and on top of that you become a mother when, of course, you will never see yourself as the first of the line ever again.
我们无法独自完成这项工作，这就是我的职业最神奇的地方，我也意识到这是从第一天起就吸引我的地方。让我感到惊讶的是，当我还是个青少年时，里面包含着对名气的渴望。我当时想：哇，真的吗？我？他们竟然在谈论这个或那个。尽管如此，你还是会从中获得一种多巴胺的高潮，尤其是当你还很年轻的时候，但那不会持久。那会消失的。如果你在朝着好的方向成长，身边有能对你讲真话、帮你过滤掉所有废话的家人，最重要的是，当你成为母亲时，当然，你永远不会再把自己当成第一顺位了。
The priorities will change immediately for the rest of your life. You're not the number one on the call sheet at home. Yeah. You know what I mean? No, never. But for the rest of my life, I're not the number one on the call sheet at home. Yeah. You know what I mean? No, never, but for the rest of my life, I will never be and I don't want to. And that's like the biggest amount of happiness in my life comes from that.
余生的首要任务会立刻发生改变。在家里，通告单上排第一的可不是你。对。你知道我的意思吗？不，绝不。但在余下的生命中，在家里，通告单上排第一的可不是你。对。你知道我的意思吗？不，绝不，但在余下的生命中，我永远不会，我也不想。我生活中最大的一笔快乐就来源于此。
And I realized that because I started so young, then when I was like 20 something, I had already gone through a lot of like emotions related to that to, oh, what is it, to get that attention. And one thing is to get a feeling of satisfaction if you're getting a good review or recognition from your peers because you've worked on something and you were so scared about it and you have connected.
我意识到这一点是因为我出道太早了，所以在我20出头的时候，我已经经历了很多与此相关的情绪——哦，那种获得关注的感觉是怎样的。如果你得到了好评，或者因为你参与了一项让你感到无比恐惧并成功引起共鸣的作品而得到了同行的认可，那这种满足感是真实的。
And that is a real thing. Okay. But the other thing that I was flipping out about when I was, I don't know, 17, 18, 19, it doesn't last long. Those years I was surprised. So how come I don't feel the same thing as I felt three years ago? That doesn't last forever. No, it lasts very little.
那是一件真切存在的事。好吧。但另一件让我当年十七八九岁时感到震惊的事，就是它并不持久。那些年我很惊讶：怎么回事，为什么我的感觉跟三年前不一样了？那不会永远持续下去。不，它持续的时间非常短暂。
It's like a friend of mine, a psychiatrist friend of mine was saying, it's actually one having a very, being very exposed to fame at a very young age is one of the things that can put you on higher risk for depression. And it makes total sense because at the end of the day, it's like when you are super addicted to a video game or gambling, or it's like this high that will have a dramatic drop and it's just dopamine and it is like that. Yeah. And we will be right back.
就像我的一个精神科医生朋友所说的那样，事实上，在很年轻的时候过度暴露于名气之中，是让你面临更高抑郁风险的因素之一。这完全说得通，因为归根结底，这就好像你对电子游戏或赌博极度上瘾，或者就像这种高潮之后会迎来急剧的坠落，这纯粹就是多巴胺，事实就是这样。我们马上回来。
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So one of the relationships I'm most proud of is the one between me and Scotty. We've been together 17 years. That's a long time, isn't it? But it takes work to be in any relationship for that long. And if you do the work, the rewards are just numerous and incredible and you end up being closer than ever.
本节目由BetterHelp赞助播出。我最引以为傲的关系之一就是我和斯科蒂之间的关系。我们已经在一起17年了。时间真长，不是吗？但维持任何长期关系都需要付出努力。如果你付出了努力，回报将是无数的、不可思议的，你们最终会比以往任何时候都亲密。
And it really worth doing the work to stay in it. Because a common misconception about relationships is they have to be easy to be right. But sometimes the best ones happen when both people put in the work to make them great together. So therapy can be a place to work through the challenges you face in all your relationships, whether it's with friends, work,
为了维持这段关系而付出努力绝对是值得的。因为关于亲密关系的一个常见误区是，它们必须轻而易举才是对的。但有时候，最好的关系反而是双方共同努力让彼此变得更优秀时造就的。所以，心理咨询可以成为解决你在所有关系中面临的挑战的一个途径，无论是与朋友、工作、
your significant other, or anyone. We don't do couples therapy, we've never done couples therapy, but we do separate therapy and it always works great. And when we get back together, we learn from therapy and it only makes our relationship stronger and healthier. It really, really works.
另一半，还是任何人。我们不做伴侣咨询，我们从未做过伴侣咨询，但我们做独立的心理咨询，而且效果总是很好。当我们重新聚在一起时，我们从心理咨询中吸取经验，这只会让我们的关系更强大、更健康。这真的非常、非常管用。
If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Become your own soulmate whether you're looking for one or not. Visit BetterHelp.com slash SmartList today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash SmartList. Our thanks to Stitch Fix for supporting this episode.
如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在网上进行，旨在为你提供便利、灵活且适合你日程的安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与持证心理咨询师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。无论你是否在寻找灵魂伴侣，先成为你自己的灵魂伴侣吧。今天就访问BetterHelp.com/SmartList，首月即可享受九折优惠。网址是BetterHelpHELP.com/SmartList。感谢Stitch Fix对本期节目的支持。
This year you can make great style effortlessly easy with Stitch Fix. Stitch Fix stylists just get you. They do all the work giving you the time to focus on your resolutions and everything else on your plate. Stitch Fix is an easy way to get clothes that fit you without having to endlessly browse through options or break the bank. Think of them as your style partner. Your stylist will learn about your tastes and collaborate with you on looks you'll love. With your choices in mind and a wide range of sizes available, from extra small to 3XL,
今年，借助Stitch Fix，你可以毫不费力地轻松打造绝佳时尚。Stitch Fix的造型师简直太懂你了。他们包揽了所有的繁重工作，让你有时间专注于自己的新年决心以及手头的其他一切事务。Stitch Fix是一种轻松获得适合你的衣服的好方法，无需无休止地浏览各种选择，也不会花光你的积蓄。把他们当作你的时尚伴侣吧。你的造型师会了解你的品味，并与你合作打造你一定会喜欢的造型。结合你的选择和从超小码到3XL的各种尺码，
they'll find your perfect fit and send you clothes hand-picked just for you. They have over a thousand brands and styles and do the work of choosing the best options for you. They'll even show you how to wear head-to-toe outfits so you can just get dressed and go. And if you don't love something, just send it back. Shipping returns and exchanges are always free.
他们会为你找到最合身的衣服，并为你量身挑选。他们拥有上千个品牌和风格，并为你挑选出最佳选项。他们甚至会向你展示如何搭配全身造型，这样你只需穿上衣服就可以出门了。如果你有哪件不那么喜欢，直接退回即可。运费、退货和换货永远都是免费的。
I love the convenience of Stitch Fix myself. I took the quiz, they kind of lined me up with everything that I love. I talked to a stylist and I got my fix on. I just, because I can't dress myself. It's really, really sad. If it was up to me, I'd wear sweats and a T-shirt every day, but I can't walk out of the house that way. So Stitch Fix helps me with everything. Thanks, Stitch Fix. They just get me and they'll get you to try it today at stitchfix.com slash smartlist and you'll get 25% off when you keep everything in your fix that stitchfix.com slash smartlist.
我自己非常喜欢Stitch Fix的便利性。我做了测试，他们几乎把所有我喜欢的东西都给我搭配好了。我跟一位造型师聊过，然后我就搞定我的穿搭了。因为我自己实在不会穿搭。这真的很悲哀。如果全凭我自己的话，我每天都会穿着运动裤和T恤，但我不能那样走出家门。所以Stitch Fix在各方面都帮了我。谢谢Stitch Fix。他们太懂我了，也会懂你的，今天就去stitchfix.com/smartlist试一试吧，如果你留下了你挑选的所有衣服，还能享受75折优惠，网址是stitchfix.com/smartlist。
Stitchfix.com slash smartlist. Smartlist is brought to you in part by Helix. So guys, we've been talking about Helix for a long time now. I just ordered another one, the Midnight Lux. It's awesome. It's got like a medium feels, it's not too soft, not too hard, my Goldilux. And then it also has, it's good for side sleepers like I am.
Stitchfix.com/smartlist。Smartlist部分内容由Helix赞助播出。伙计们，我们已经聊Helix很久了。我刚又订购了一个，Midnight Lux。太棒了。它有一种中等的触感，不过软也不过硬，简直是我的“金发姑娘”床垫。而且它很适合像我这样侧睡的人。
I never sleep on my stomach or my back really. And it's got enhanced lumbar for my back when I sleep on my side. It's got great support, I love it. The Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including award-winning Luxe collection, the newly released Helix Elite collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids Hélix SleepQuiz.com. straight to your door free of charge. Helix knows there's no better way to test out a new mattress than by sleeping on it in your own home. That's why they offer a 100 night trial
我睡觉时从来不趴着，也几乎不仰睡。当我侧睡时，它为我的背部提供了增强的腰椎支撑。它的支撑力极佳，我爱死它了。Helix产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括屡获殊荣的Luxe系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为高大体型睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至还有专为儿童设计的床垫，访问HelixSleepQuiz.com即可选购。直接免费送货上门。Helix深知，测试新床垫的最好方法就是在自己家里睡上一觉。这就是为什么他们提供100晚试睡，
and a 10 to 15 year warranty to try out your new Helix mattress. Helix is offering 20% of all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixsleep.com slash smartless and use code Helixpartner20. This is their best offer yet and it won't last long. Helixsleep.com slash smartlist code Helixpartner20
以及10到15年的保修期，让你放心体验全新的Helix床垫。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠以及两个免费枕头。访问helixsleep.com/smartlist并使用代码Helixpartner20。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，且限时提供。helixsleep.com/smartlist，优惠码Helixpartner20。
with Helix Better Sleep starts now. All right, back to the show. I think you put it in the right place when I remember telling my kids I have three boys and a stepson. So four boys in the house, it's crazy. And I remember saying when my older boys were younger, sort of six, seven, and people want to take photos
从Helix开始，安稳睡眠即刻开启。好了，回到节目中。当我想起曾对孩子们说我有三个男孩和一个继子时，我觉得自己把这件事放在了正确的位置。家里有四个男孩，太疯狂了。我记得当我的大儿子们还小的时候，大概六七岁左右，你在外面时人们会想要拍照
or whatever when you're out. And I remember explaining that to them, and it was through explaining to them the idea of, these people don't know me, they think they do, they want my picture because they think something else. And when I said it out loud and put it in the right place, it changed everything for me once I actually said it out loud. And it put it in a place that was much more acceptable
或者别的什么。我记得我向他们解释过这件事，是通过向他们灌输这样一个观念：这些人并不认识我，他们以为自己认识，他们想要我的照片是因为他们脑海中的某种想象。当我大声说出来并把它放在正确的位置时，一旦我真的大声说出来，一切都改变了。它被放在了一个更容易被接受的位置，
and it stopped affecting, I've said this many times, as long as you don't peg your happiness to how other people think about you, then you'll be okay. And you can kind of keep that right sized. You know what I mean? Yeah. Keep it in the right place. And I was also thinking about that right size. You know what I mean? Yeah. Keep it in the right place. And I was also thinking about something else
它不再影响——我已经说过很多次了，只要你不把你的幸福挂钩在别人对你的看法上，你就会没事的。你可以把这种心态保持在恰当的尺度上。你知道我的意思吗？对。把它放在正确的位置。我也在思考这种恰当的尺度。你知道我的意思吗？对。把它放在正确的位置。我还想到了另一件事，
you said Penelope, which is interesting. And I don't know, I'm gonna open this up to everybody. Really, you're talking about staying a student. And I've been thinking so much more in the last couple of years now that I'm 53. I mean, I could play 48, but. Yeah, easily. Thank you.
佩内洛普你说的那些话，非常有趣。我不知道，我想把这个话题向所有人敞开。真的，你谈到了保持学生心态。我这几年想得越来越多了，现在我都53岁了。我是说，我可以演48岁，但是。对，轻而易举。谢谢。
Maybe even 48. No, I'm 40. Sure, maybe 40. Thank you. I really appreciate it.. Sure, maybe 40, thank you. I really appreciate it. But one of the things I've been thinking about is this idea of staying, I was saying to somebody, I want to stay in the student section of life, not just in my work.
甚至48岁都可以。不，我40岁。当然，也许40岁。谢谢。我真的很感激。当然，也许40岁，谢谢。我真的很感激。但我一直在思考的事情之一，就是这种保持——我曾对某人说过，我想留在人生的学生区，不仅仅是在工作中。
I want to really feel, I don't want to be an expert, and like all of us, I can talk like an expert sometimes about stuff and have a lot of conviction. It's so important in this life to stay in the student section, I think. Don't you agree? I agree. I agree.
我想真切地感受到，我不想当专家，就像我们所有人一样，有时我可以就某些事情说得像个专家一样，并且充满信念。我认为，在这个生命中，留在学生区是如此重要。难道你不同意吗？我同意。我同意。
And I feel like when you have kids, immediately you are putting that place forever because it's such a lesson every day and so much wisdom that comes from just the total honesty that all the kids have. Yeah, they don't care. It's a great reminder that you know nothing until you learn it. Like you get to watch them learn things
我觉得当你有了孩子，你立刻就会永远处于那个位置，因为每天都是一堂课，孩子们身上那种绝对的诚实蕴含着太多的智慧。对，他们才不在乎呢。这是一个很好的提醒，提醒你直到学会之前你什么都不懂。就像你可以看着他们学习新事物，
or get experience with things for the very first time. And we forget that moment for us. For instance, somebody sent us a gift yesterday and there was like a cassette tape in it, one of those old audio cassette tapes. And my 12 year old daughter said, what's this? And I said, well, that's a cassette. She said a cassette, what's a cassette?
或者第一次体验各种事物。而我们却忘记了我们当年的那一刻。例如，昨天有人给我们送了一份礼物，里面有一盘盒式磁带，就是那种老式的音频盒式磁带。我12岁的女儿问，这是什么？我说，哦，那是盒式磁带。她说盒式磁带，什么是盒式磁带？
I said, well, it's a, I mean, how do you describe what a cassette is? I said, what's that? The same thing happened to me last month and I was shocked. She didn't know how to open up that cassette box, that clear see-through cassette box. And you said, this is what daddy used to put in his Shirako.
我说，这，我的意思是，你怎么形容什么是盒式磁带？我说，那是什么？我上个月也遇到了同样的事情，我当时震惊了。她竟然不知道怎么打开那个磁带盒，那个透明的磁带盒。然后你说，这就是爸爸以前放在他的白子（Shirako）里的东西。
Yeah, exactly. I said, I used to have hundreds of these, these are what albums used to be on. She goes, really, this is, there's music on this? I said, yeah. I said, open it up and put it in. She's, it took five minutes. How did you have a big point?
对，完全正确。我说，我以前有几百个这东西，以前的专辑就是长这样的。她就说，真的吗，这里面，这里面有音乐？我说，对。我说，把它打开然后放进去。她，这花了我五分钟。你怎么会有个好观点？
There was a little, there was a little like a Walkman that came with the gift. No way. And it took her five minutes to open up. have a point? There was a little like a Walkman that came with the gift. No way. And it took her five minutes to open up. I finally had to take it from her. I said, let me show you how to open, she almost broke it. She didn't know how to open up the clip. Anyway, so yeah, it's a great reminder
那里面有个小巧的，送的礼物里带了一个像Walkman一样的小玩意。绝不可能。她花了五分钟才打开。有个好观点？那里面有个小巧的，送的礼物里带了一个像Walkman一样的小玩意。绝不可能。她花了五分钟才打开。我最后不得不从她手里拿过来。我说，让我来教你怎么打开，她差点把它弄坏。她根本不知道怎么打开那个卡扣。总之，所以，是的，这是一个很好的提醒
that you just don't realize what you don't know if you don't keep up your radar that you're willing to learn. Also age helps, age helps not giving a shit. Like, right, the older you get, you're just like, I'm too tired and old to care. Well, you maybe start caring about things that are actually important. And all the things that are related
如果你不保持你的雷达开启、不随时准备学习，你就根本不会意识到自己对哪些东西一无所知。还有，年龄有帮助，年龄能帮你做到不在乎。就像，对吧，你年纪越大，你就会觉得：我太累太老了，才不在乎呢。好吧，你可能开始关心那些真正重要的事情。以及所有相关的事情
about how you are perceived. For sure. By people that you don't know, which is different than, of course, if you have a job like the one that we have, at the end of the day, you are doing that to try to move energy in people, to try to... we make movies for that reason, not to change the world, but you want to connect with people.
关于你如何被看待。当然。被你不认识的人，这当然不同于，如果你有一份像我们这样的工作，到头来，你做这件事是为了尝试调动人们的情感，尝试……我们拍电影就是为了这个原因，不是为了改变世界，而是你想与人们建立连接。
Yeah. I want to know, like, I want to go back to ballet. I had no idea about ballet. That's crazy This did you find that? How many years did you take ballet like 17? 17 years. Do you still dance? Well, when I get the chance to I Might do a musical soon again like I did nine. You were great in nine I went I thank you
对。我想知道，比如，我想回到芭蕾舞。我对芭蕾舞一无所知。这太疯狂了。你是什么时候发现的？你学了多少年芭蕾，大概17年？17年。你现在还跳吗？嗯，当我有机会的时候。我可能很快又会演音乐剧，就像我演《九》那样。你在《九》里演得太棒了。我去，谢谢你
I loved making that movie and I went back to dancing for like six months or something like that. So I'm always looking for reasons to go back. That's great. Wow, so you don't have the wear and tear on a person's body of 17 years of being on your toes. Yeah. Like you have any kind of like-
我很喜欢拍那部电影，我又回去跳了大概六个月的舞之类的。所以我一直在寻找回去的理由。那太棒了。哇，那你没有那种跳了17年脚尖舞对身体造成的损耗吗？对。就像你有什么样的——
Your toes still hurt? Yeah. No, but I mean, I got used to that. You know, when you are bleeding and your nails are like, you lose them, they get really dark and then they fall off and you have to keep dancing and smiling. And the discipline that it gives you, it helped me a lot because I started to work
你的脚趾现在还疼吗？对。不，但是，我已经习惯了。你知道，当你流血、指甲，你会失去它们，它们变得非常黑然后脱落，你还得继续跳舞和微笑。它赋予你的纪律性，对我帮助很大，因为我很小就开始工作
as an actress so young and I had the discipline from that that was so much harder than anything I have done. I'm sure. I can't believe it. You talked a little bit about, we're just sort of just to swing back to like what's important stuff. And I, so both you and your partner are film actors
当演员，我从那里面学到的纪律性，比我做过的任何事情都要艰难得多。我敢肯定。我简直不敢相信。你刚才稍微谈到了，我们只是为了转回正题，谈谈什么是重要的东西。而且我，所以你和你的伴侣都是电影演员
and actors at the highest level and very much in demand. You've made lots of films. And yet now you've started a family and I presume that you still live in Spain, yeah? Or that you moved back. Like you spent very many years where you were doing like, it seemed like you did so many films,
而且是最高水平的演员，非常抢手。你们拍了很多电影。然而现在你们组建了家庭，我想你们应该还是住在西班牙吧？或者你们搬回去了。就像你度过了很多年的时间，在那期间你一直在拍，看起来你拍了好多电影，
and I listed off all the awards and nominations. And yet now, do you find yourself, have you put that in a different place now? Like now that you've moved, and you live in Europe, and you don't live a different place now, like now that you move and you live in Europe and you don't live here in Los Angeles and you've kind of, do you feel that you've been able to carve out a kind of a different life? Very different, very different.
我数了数所有的奖项和提名。然而现在，你发现自己，你现在把它放在一个不同的位置了吗？就像现在你搬家了，你住在欧洲，你没有住在不同的地方，像现在你搬家了，你住在欧洲，你没有住在洛杉矶，你有点，你觉得你已经能够开辟出一种不同的生活了吗？非常不同，非常不同。
Where the total priority, the number one priority is the family. Also most of my family, mom and sisters and most of them are there in Spain. My brother and nephew are here in LA and I miss them so much. But I mean, life always brings us here, like maybe in the summer, Christmas or both,
总优先级，第一优先级是家庭。而且我的大部分家人，妈妈和姐姐们以及他们大部分人都在西班牙。我弟弟和侄子在洛杉矶，我非常想念他们。但我的意思是，生活总会把我们带到这里，比如可能在夏天、圣诞节或者两个都来，
and come here for work. And I lived here for 15 years in LA and I loved it. But we just wanted to be there raising the children because family is very important for us. Yeah, yeah, of course. What's the atmosphere like there where you live in Spain with respect to Hollywood and the media and fame and paparazzi and all that kind of stuff? Can you live a very sort of normal in quotes life there
然后来这里工作。我在洛杉矶住了15年，我很喜欢它。但我们只想在那里抚养孩子们，因为家庭对我们来说非常重要。对，对，当然。你们在西班牙居住的地方，关于好莱坞、媒体、名气和狗仔队之类的氛围是怎样的？你在那里能过上一种非常，加引号的，正常的生活吗
as opposed to here? Yes. Oh, good. Well, when I was here, I mean, there was a way to do it also. I mean, it depends what kind of place you go to, you know, you know how it is. And there I can do everything.
而不是像在这里这样？是的。噢，太好了。嗯，当我在这里的时候，我的意思是，也有办法做到这一点。我的意思是，这取决于你去什么地方，你知道的，你懂的。而在那里我可以做任何事情。
I can go to school, go to the supermarket, go to a public gym, go to everywhere, everywhere. And this is where I want, I could not give up having a normal life. Wait, you can go to a public gym? Of course, and I can go everywhere. And even if they do recognize you, do they treat celebrity with such reverence there
我可以去学校，去超市，去公共健身房，去任何地方，任何地方。这就是我想要的，我不能放弃过正常的生活。等等，你可以去公共健身房？当然，我可以去任何地方。而且即使他们认出了你，他们对待名人的态度也会像这里那样带着那种崇敬吗
like they do here? I think it's a little too big here. No, I think it's not a surprise to see us there. So, and also everything ends up being close to the area where I grew up and it feels like if you knew all your neighbors, you know, it feels very easy going and people are very nice. And is Javier from the same area?
就像他们在这里做的那样？我觉得这里有点过于夸张了。不，我觉得在那里看到我们并不稀奇。所以，而且一切最终都在我长大的那个区域附近，感觉就像你认识所有的邻居一样，你知道的，感觉非常随和，人们也非常友善。何塞维尔也是同一个地方的人吗？
We was actually born in Canary Islands, but he was raised more in the city and I was raised more out of Madrid. But also in LA I had no problems where I lived here and I feel like it's more choosing where you go to. If you're gonna go to a place looking for attention or you go to a place so you can leave your day. It's the vibe you put out too, right?
他实际上出生在加那利群岛，但他更多是在城市里长大的，而我更多是在马德里郊外长大的。但在洛杉矶，我住在这里也没有遇到什么问题，我觉得这更多取决于你选择去哪里。如果你去一个寻找关注的地方，或者你去一个可以过日子的地方。这也是你散发出的氛围，对吧？
Oh, it's also what you wear too. Like if you look all great and fabulous, or if you look like you're trying to hide with a hat and big glasses, people, you stand out like a sore thumb. You draw more attention. Yeah, but if you just like, if there's no hiding whatsoever,
哦，这也是你穿什么的问题。比如你看起来光鲜亮丽、光彩照人，或者你看起来像是在试图用帽子和大墨镜躲藏，人们会像大拇指上的疮疤一样显眼。你会吸引更多的注意力。对，但如果你只是，如果没有丝毫的藏匿，
it's just a little sweatshirt or something. Well, we had a guest on, one of our guests who's a friend of the show, I won't name him, but he had, years ago I'd gone to his house, one of the biggest film actors on the planet. And we went to his house and he said, and I was giving him a lift home.
只是穿一件小运动衫什么的。好吧，我们曾有一位嘉宾，我们的嘉宾之一，也是这个节目的朋友，我不说他的名字了，但他有，几年前我去过他家，他是地球上最大的电影演员之一。我们去了他家，他说，我正顺便送他回家。
And we get to his gate that was barely like a gate. And then he said, just punching the code. I said, what's the code for the 2468? I said, come on, man. No, 2468. And then you could walk around it if you want. We get up to his house and we walk in and the front door is open.
我们到了他的大门，那门几乎算不上是个大门。然后他说，直接输密码。我说，那个2468是什么密码？我说，得了吧，老兄。不，就是2468。然后如果你想的话，你还可以绕着它走。我们走到他家，走进去，前门是开着的。
And I said, dude, what are you doing? You're crazy. I mean, this is guys like that. And he goes, I don't live like a prisoner. Right. And if I put that vibe out in the world. Yeah, yeah, it's true. It's true.
我说，老兄，你在干什么？你疯了。我的意思是，像这样的家伙。他说，我可不以囚犯的方式生活。对。如果我把这种氛围释放到世界上。对，对，这是真的，这是真的。
Probably take less attention like that. I totally, by the way, totally. I'm like, if somebody's gonna get me, they're gonna get me. If somebody's, you know. Well, why do you have that, you have that sign that says Sean Hayes lives here in front of your house. Yeah, but I mean, you can see behind some hedges.
这样可能会少引起一些注意。顺便说一句，我完全赞同。我觉得，如果有人要抓我，他们就会抓我。如果有人，你知道的。好吧，为什么你会有那个，你的房子前面挂着写着“肖恩·海斯住在这里”的牌子。对，但我的意思是，你可以透过一些树篱看到。
Wait, listen, Penelope, before we go any further, I wanna ask you, and this is a tough question and you can feel free to not answer it when he always cut it out. Real Madrid or Atlético Madrid? You know what? I don't care. I know that, no, no, I mean, I do because
听着，佩内洛普，在我们继续之前，我想问你，这是一个棘手的问题，如果你不想回答随时可以不答，当他总是剪掉它的时候。皇家马德里还是马德里竞技？你知道吗？我不在乎。我知道，不，不，我的意思是，我在乎，因为
that's another thing that changes when you are a mother and suddenly you see they like football, but then you start loving football too. I have a family that is from a lethico family from Barcelona, club family from Real Madrid. And I think they're amazing teams, but I am loving everything more Real Madrid. What can I say?
当你成为母亲时，另一件改变的事情是，突然间你发现他们喜欢足球，然后你也开始喜欢足球了。我的家庭里有来自马竞的家庭，来自巴塞罗那的俱乐部家庭，来自皇马的俱乐部家庭。我认为他们都是出色的球队，但我更喜欢皇马的一切。我能说什么呢？
Very, very good. I love, I love a huge football fan and I'm obsessed and actually like both those teams as well. They have great players. We're recording this right around the holiday season and are you a big holiday fan? Do you love Christmas or what? I don't know what you guys celebrate.
非常，非常棒。我喜欢，我超级喜欢足球，而且我对此很着迷，实际上这两支球队我也都很喜欢。他们有优秀的球员。我们录制这期节目的时候正值假期临近，你是个超级节日迷吗？你喜欢圣诞节还是怎么的？我不知道你们庆祝什么。
Do you guys go skiing? Do you like the beach instead? It's just about being with the family. And since I have my kids, I really see, I get to experience again Christmas like when I was little, and it's like having a second chance like to experience it, to experience that magic
你们会去滑雪吗？还是更喜欢海滩？这纯粹是为了和家人在一起。自从有了孩子，我真的看到，我又能像小时候那样体验圣诞节了，这就像是有了第二次机会去体验它，去体验那种魔法
and it's incredible. Of course. I love it again so much. For a few years I, it was just like one more part of the year, but now it's a big deal. It's become a big deal. My three year old this morning, he was saying that he wanted to get this truck.
这太不可思议了。当然。我又重新非常喜欢它了。有几年我，它只是这一年中的又一部分，但现在这是一件大事。这已经变成了一件大事。我三岁的儿子今天早上，他说他想要买这辆卡车。
It was like a crane thing. And I said, okay, well, we'll see if Santa comes in. He goes, no, you buy it. And I said, no, no, no. We're gonna see if Santa goes, Dada, you buy it. But how old? How old is he? He's three and a half.
就像那种起重机。我说，好吧，那我们看看圣诞老人会不会来。他说，不，你买。我说，不，不，不。我们要看看圣诞老人去不去，爸爸，你买。但是多大？他多大？他三岁半。
Oh. Yeah. Now, what do you think is too old to be still 2.5. Oh! Yeah. 2.5. 2.5. I know. What do you think is too old to be still in the Santa world? I'm saying this gently, because I don't know how young our listeners are. I feel is when they're ready. Yeah, when they're ready.
哦。对。现在，你觉得多大年龄还沉浸在圣诞老人的世界里就算太大了？我问得很委婉，因为我不知道我们的听众有多年轻。我觉得是当他们准备好的时候。对，当他们准备好的时候。
When they're ready, when they're ready, and maybe your son is ready now. I know, does it help? I know, it's a little shocking, but when they're ready, they're gonna ask in a different way. He doesn't think that I'm Santa. No, no, no, he's just saying that he doesn't want to wait
当他们准备好了，当他们准备好了，也许你的儿子现在已经准备好了。我知道，这有帮助吗？我知道，这有点令人震惊，但当他们准备好时，他们会以不同的方式问。他不认为我是圣诞老人。不，不，不，他只是说他不想等
for Santa. Look at this guy, look at this guy. Oh, adorable. Was he on the potty there? I love it. He looks very excited about his movement. He's, daddy, look. Believe me, he's, I asked him this morning also,
圣诞老人了。看看这家伙，看看这家伙。哦，太可爱了。他当时是在坐盆便便吗？我太喜欢了。他看起来对自己的排便感到非常兴奋。他是，爸爸，看。相信我，他，我今天早上也问过他，
I'm not gonna get to it in the week, but I asked him who's the boss and he said me. I said, you're not the boss anyway. I remember in Christmas, like my mom used to get us so much more in debt than we already were. Right, Christmas was like the number one thing in her life. She would max out her credit cards and mortgage the house just so we could have presents.
我这周不会讲到这个，但我问他谁才是老板，他说是我。我说，不管怎样你可不是老板。我记得在圣诞节的时候，我妈妈让我们背负了比原本还要多的债务。对，圣诞节就像她生命中的头等大事。她会刷爆信用卡，把房子拿去抵押，只为了让我们有礼物。
And as I got older, I'm like, I don't know if this is the greatest business model for our home. Like maybe. You're leaving us with another gift too, mom. That's debt. Yeah. By the way, it's a very sort of,
随着我长大，我心想，我不知道这对于我们的家庭来说是不是最好的商业模式。也许吧。妈，你也给我们留下了另一件礼物。那就是债务。对。顺便说一句，这非常，
it's very much symbolic of like sort of the age that we live in. You watch these ads up now on TV and they're all like, everybody's gonna go to one of these big box stores and they're like, well, dad needs a CD player. My son needs a new big screen TV. And I'm like, what kind of money do people have that they're spending like? You know what I mean? Like having these huge, it seems crazy.
这非常象征着我们生活的时代。你在电视上看到这些广告，它们全都是，每个人都要去那些大型仓储超市，他们就像，哦，爸爸需要一个CD播放器。我儿子需要一台新的大屏幕电视。我就想，人们到底有多少钱才能这样挥霍？你知道我的意思吗？就像拥有这些庞大的东西，这看起来太疯狂了。
Anyway, I don't want to get it. I also remember really quick, just while we're on the subject, my mom constantly with a cigarette hanging out of her mouth, constantly 24 hours a day filling the stockings by the fire. And then by the tree that was real with her lit cigarette, just putting stuff under the tree. That was my dad too. Really?
总之，我不想扯远。我也很快地想起来，就在我们聊这个话题的时候，我妈妈嘴里总是叼着一根香烟，没日没夜24小时在壁炉旁装满长筒袜。然后在挂着她点燃的香烟的真圣诞树旁，把东西一件件塞到树底下。我爸爸也是这样。真的吗？
Really? Smoking in the house and doctors telling him, you have to quit. And he was saying to us, this is a complot of the family is not true that I have to quit You are all talking to the doctor What a character how is this the smoking in Europe? Still a lot of smokers in Europe correct much less much less
真的吗？在家里抽烟，医生告诉他：“你必须戒烟。”他对我们说：“这是家里的一个阴谋，我根本不用戒烟，这并不是真的。你们所有人都在替医生说话。”真是个奇葩。欧洲的抽烟情况怎么样？欧洲现在还是有很多烟民对吧？少多了，少多了。
I mean I grew up in a spending time every day in a hair salon because my mom owned a hair salon Everyone was smoking in front of all the kids. The combination of that, plus all the toxicity of all the products. Can you imagine? You can smoke in the elevator over in Europe. No, no, it was... There's ashtrays in the elevators. When?
我的意思是，我在美发沙龙里度过了每一天，因为我妈妈开了一家美发沙龙。每个人都在所有孩子面前抽烟。这再加上所有产品毒性的组合。你能想象吗？在欧洲的电梯里你都可以抽烟。不，不，那是……电梯里有烟灰缸。什么时候？
Yeah, when I was in Paris a couple of years ago, there were still ashtrays in the elevators. I don't know, I think it's like now or in every... No, no bien sûr. Je ne sais pas, je pense que c'est pas vrai. Non, c'est pas vrai. Non, c'est pas encore. Non, non, bien sûr. Pas du tout, pas du tout. Non, non, non, non. Wait a second, Penelope,
对，几年前我在巴黎的时候，电梯里居然还有烟灰缸。我不知道，我想现在或者每个……不，当然不是。我不知道，我觉得这不是真的。不，这不是真的。不，还不是。不，不，当然不是。一点也不，一点也不。不，不，不，不。等一下，佩内洛普，
comment de nombreuses langues, tu sais, tout le monde qui vit en France sait comme cinq langues. Oui. Je parle italien, spanish, anglais, avec cet accent, que je ne sais pas quand,
有多少种语言，你知道的，每个住在法国的人都知道大约五种语言。是的。我说意大利语，西班牙语，英语，带着这个口音，我不知道什么时候，
je vais le faire. Et je suis petit, oui. Oh, mon Dieu, on peut parler français. Ah, OK. Si tu veux, mais... J'ai pas essayé. Oui, moi aussi. Bon, bon, qu'est-ce que vous voulez? C'est une petite édition. C'est pas français, c'est bien. Je peux l'entendre.
我要说这个。而且我很小，是的。噢，天哪，我们可以说法语。啊，好吧。如果你想的话，但是……我没试过。对，我也是。好，好，你们想要什么？这是一个小版本。这不是法语，挺好的。我能听懂。
Ah, bien sûr. Alors, Penelope, vous savez, j'ai bien entendu, c'est un plaisir de vous rencontrer. C'est très bien que vous ayez fait le show. Je l'aime, c'est très bien. Je l'aime, c'est très bien. Je Penelope, you know, obviously I don't know you. It's such a pleasure to meet you. It's so nice you're doing the show.
啊，当然。那么，佩内洛普，你知道的，我当然不认识你。很高兴见到你。你能来这个节目真是太好了。我喜欢它，这非常好。我喜欢它，这非常好。佩内洛普，你知道的，显然我不认识你。认识你真是太高兴了。你能来做这个节目真是太好了。
Thank you. No, I love it. This is so much fun. I could be here for five hours straight. Okay, great. Well, we have two minutes. So, no, I'm kidding. Where are you going?
谢谢。不，我很喜欢。这太有趣了。我可以连续在这里待五个小时。好吧，太好了。嗯，我们还有两分钟。所以，不，我开玩笑的。你要去哪儿？
No, we have. Sean, believe me, Sean has eight hours that he needs to fill today. So this is perfect. If you could just stick around until seven tonight. No, it seems like, you know, there's certain points in my life that I can remember changed me and I grew from.
不，我们有。肖恩，相信我，肖恩今天有八个小时需要消磨。所以这太完美了。如果你能一直待到今晚七点的话。不，看起来，你知道，我生命中的某些时刻，我能记得它们改变了我，让我成长了。
I'm gonna sneeze at you! Sorry. Oh, I love that. You can't announce it. That was the best. There's our first ever sneeze. That is, I love that. Sometimes I sneeze eight times in a row.
我要对你打喷嚏了！抱歉。哦，我喜欢这样。你都不能提前宣布一下。那太棒了。这是我们有史以来的第一个喷嚏。那是，我太喜欢了。有时我会连打八个喷嚏。
Oh my God, I hope not. It's always three. That's gonna happen. I did it today. I did it this morning too. I think it's going around. I sneeze like. What about people who muffled their sneezes?
哦天哪，希望不要。总是三个。那总会发生。我今天就这样了。我今天早上也这样。我觉得这是一种流感。我打喷嚏就像。那些强忍住喷嚏的人呢？
It's my favorite thing to do. And people that stifle them, I'm like, no. I can't. Just let it out. You're depriving yourself of one of the greatest releases ever. Yeah, that was to be bad for you. Yeah, I'm sorry guys. Yeah, sneeze edging is no good.
这是我最喜欢做的事。而那些强行憋住的人，我就想，不。我做不到。就让它释放出来吧。你剥夺了自己有史以来最棒的释放方式之一。对，那对你不好。对，对不起各位。对，憋喷嚏可不好。
All right, keep going Sean. What was your, Sean, keep going. My thing was there's certain points in my life that I can recall changed me, where I grew from them, where I learned and they were- Fill and joke here. Yeah. They were experiences that made me grow up quickly and realize and see things differently.
好了，肖恩，继续。你的那个，肖恩，继续。我的事情是，我生命中的某些时刻我可以回想起来，它们改变了我，我在其中成长，我从中学习，它们是——在这里插个笑话。对。它们是让我迅速成长、意识到并以不同视角看待事物的经历。
And you seem like, not again, not knowing you, you seem like you have an amazing no bullshit meter. Like you're- Oh, thank you. That's a great compliment. You can call it out right away. Were there certain moments in your life that taught you that, that you can remember,
而且你看上去，再次强调，由于不了解你，你似乎拥有惊人的“胡扯探测器”。就像你——哦，谢谢。真是个极好的赞美。你能马上指出来。你生命中的某些时刻是否教会了你这一点，让你能够记住，
you're like, you know what, because of this experience, I have now changed and I'm gonna call you on that now, so it doesn't happen to me again. Yes, a few things, like crucial moments in my life that I remember that were like a turning point in terms of like, oh, actually, you can respect yourself that much and it's okay. No, and it's not just okay.
你会觉得，你知道吗，因为这段经历，我现在改变了，我要当面指出这一点，这样它就不会再发生在我身上了。是的，有一些事情，比如我生命中关键的时刻，我记得它们就像是一个转折点，比如说，哦，实际上，你可以那样尊重自己，而且这完全没问题。不，这不仅仅是“没问题”。
I feel so much happier. And moments like this are, I feel like if you get to live a long life, those things you remember before you go, I'm sure. Yeah, do you remember what some of those are or what moments, if you wanna share them? For example, working with Michael, was very interesting that way because he's very, very tough.
我感到快乐得多。这样的时刻，我觉得如果你能活得很长，在你离开之前，你一定会记住那些事情，我确信。是的，你还记得其中一些是什么，或者有哪些时刻，如果你愿意分享的话？例如，与迈克尔合作，在这方面非常有趣，因为他非常非常坚强。
And I loved, we didn't have a lot of free time there. We were working really hard and nonstop, but sometimes if we had 10 minutes in between shots, I just wanted to talk to him about, without calling it that in front of him, but it was about his toughness, about the reasons why he has no problem saying no, which is sometimes harder for me.
我喜欢，我们在那里没有很多空闲时间。我们工作非常努力，一刻不停，但有时如果在镜头之间有10分钟的空闲，我只想跟他聊聊，虽然不在他面前这么叫，但那是关于他的坚强，关于他为什么能毫不费劲地说“不”的原因，这对我来说有时更难。
And he said, he answered something so brilliant. He said, you know, there is no free lunch. There is so much in that answer that I needed to hear. There's no free lunch. That advice. Yeah, there is no free lunch, meaning like if, I don't wanna give a specific example, but there are times in your life when you know,
他说，他回答得太精彩了。他说，你知道的，天下没有免费的午餐。那个回答里包含了我当时迫切需要听到的太多东西。天下没有免费的午餐。那个建议。对，天下没有免费的午餐，意思是如果，我不想举一个具体的例子，但有时在你的生活中你知道，
you have to say no to something and so many justifications and all, but this, but that will make you say, yes, you don't want to hurt somebody's feelings, you don't want to, no, no, no, no, it's too complicated. But you feel like what's the right thing to do. And he's very honest that way and has no problem saying. And then you're like, oh, I didn't know
你必须对某事说“不”，并且有那么多的理由和借口，但是这个，但是那个会让你说，好的，你不想伤害别人的感情，你不想，不，不，不，不，这太复杂了。但你觉得什么是正确的事。而且他在这方面非常诚实，说“不”毫无压力。然后你会想，哦，我以前不知道
that it's okay for me to say no. Yeah, well, that's a boundary thing, right? That's like a boundary. It's a boundary thing, meaning there is no freelance. If you don't say no when you know you have to and you accumulate too many of those, one day you're gonna explode. I know, because I had to learn that too.
我可以对别人说“不”。嗯，那是设立界限的问题，对吧？那就像是一个界限。这是一个界限问题，意思是天下没有免费的午餐。如果你在明知必须说“不”的时候没有说，而且你积压了太多这样的事情，总有一天你会崩溃的。我知道，因为我也必须学会这一点。
Well, I'd say I'm here and JB, we, Sean, you and I talked about with JB. I said, within the last year, Jason, I said to you, I really respect your ability to draw boundaries for yourself. You've gotten, you're really good. You really set a good example for me. I think it took me to get older to understand.
嗯，我会说我在这里，JB，我们，肖恩，你和我谈过关于JB的事。我说，在过去的一年里，杰森，我对你说，我真的很尊重你为自己划定界限的能力。你变得，你真的很厉害。你真的为我树立了一个好榜样。我想我需要年龄大一点才能理解。
And it is, Penelope, like you say, when you start to be able to say no or to draw a boundary and say, this is my boundary, it's so freeing because you feel you take a little bit of power back and you're able to go like, yeah, that's not okay for me. Yeah. And then, you know. It's very difficult to learn that. Yeah. Also as an actor, when actress starting very young, when you depend on others to say yes to you to work,
而且，佩内洛普，正如你所说，当你开始能够说“不”或者划定界限并说“这就是我的界限”时，那是如此的解放，因为你会觉得自己夺回了一点点主动权，并且能够说，是的，这对我是不行的。对。然后，你知道的。学会这一点非常困难。对。作为一名演员，当女演员从很小的时候开始，当你依赖别人对你点头说“yes”来获得工作时，
and then you realize that, oh, maybe I have to say no, for example, to this project. And how can I allow myself to say no to that? That's also a huge lesson. Yeah. Thank you for saying that, Will. But one of the things that I worry about is that I just, that I get meaner
然后你意识到，哦，也许我必须对这个项目说“不”。我怎么能允许自己对它说“不”呢？这也是一个巨大的教训。对，威尔，谢谢你这么说。但让我担心的事情之一是，我只是，我变得更刻薄了
or that think people will think, oh well, he's being mean or that's, right, or he's cranky. And while that might be the case, to compensate for that, I have expanded my nice side. When there are moments that I feel like I should be nicer or I should be generous in this moment or do that thing.
或者人们会认为，哦，好吧，他变刻薄了，或者那是，对吧，或者他变得暴躁了。虽然情况可能确实如此，但为了弥补这一点，我扩大了我友善的一面。每当我觉得自己应该更友善一点，或者在这个时刻应该表现得慷慨一点，或者去做那件事的时候。
I end up doing more of those things and being nicer when it is time to be nice. I see you making that. I've seen you making the effort lately. I swear to God, I'm not kidding. It's not about the no, it's about how you say the no. Yeah. How you say it and what you're saying Jason is just more honest.
我最终会做更多那样的事情，在需要友善的时候表现得更友善。我看到你在努力了。我看到你最近一直在努力。我向上帝发誓，我不是在开玩笑。这无关乎“不”，而在于你如何说这个“不”。对。你是怎么说的，杰森，你所说的只是更诚实。
Yeah. And that doesn't make you meaner. You're just more honest because behind a lot of yeses that you don't want to say there is that. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. There is no way. I learned that lesson and I'm not going back to where I was. Yeah. By the way, we are still owed seven more sneezes.
对。这并不意味着你更刻薄了。你只是更诚实了，因为在许多你并不想说但还是说了的“yes”背后，都有着那种情绪。不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。绝对不行。我吸取了这个教训，我再也不会回到过去了。对。顺便说一句，我们还欠着另外七个喷嚏呢。
Yeah. I know, but it's not happening. We'll wait. We'll be right back. SmartList gets support from ShipStation. The beginning of the year is a great time to grow your business, but if you're stuck in the trenches of daily tasks,
对。我知道，但它不会发生了。我们等会。我们马上回来。SmartList 得到 ShipStation 的支持。年初是发展业务的好时机，但如果你深陷日常琐事的泥潭，
like managing order fulfillment, you're not able to focus on what really matters, increasing sales. ShipStation easily automates shipping tasks and manages orders in one simple dashboard. Their effortless integration is everywhere you sell online, including Amazon, Etsy, eBay, Shopify, and more. Simplify and automate your shipping no matter how big your business grows. Ship Station has enterprise solutions that reduce warehouse costs and improve profitability. Over 130,000 companies have grown their e-commerce businesses with Ship Station, and 98% of companies that stick with Ship Station for a year become customers for life. Make this year your most profitable one yet with Ship Station. Use promo code smartless today at ShipStation.com to sign up for your free 30-day trial
比如管理订单配送，你就无法专注于真正重要的事情——提高销售额。ShipStation 可以轻松自动化配送任务并在一个简单的仪表板中管理订单。他们轻松的集成功能覆盖了你在网上销售的所有地方，包括亚马逊、Etsy、eBay、Shopify 等等。无论你的业务发展得有多大，都能简化和自动化你的配送。ShipStation 拥有企业级解决方案，可降低仓库成本并提高盈利能力。超过 13万家公司通过 ShipStation 发展了其电子商务业务，其中 98% 的公司在连续使用 ShipStation 一年后成为了终身客户。今年，就用 ShipStation 让你的利润达到新高。今天就在 ShipStation.com 使用促销代码 smartless 注册免费试用 30 天。
at ShipStation.com promo code smartless. [♪ music playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing, guitar playing of content with bestsellers, new releases, and exclusive originals that get you closer to the voices that can change your life. You'll find voices that motivate, sounds to soothe, stories to inspire, and personalities to encourage you along the way. You know what I checked out recently? I checked out something called Fluke. Chance, chaos, and why everything we do matters. It's called Fluke. It's really cool. It's by this social scientist, Brian Kloss. What he does, he dives deeply into the phenomenon of random chance and the chaos it can sow, taking aim at most people's neat and tidy storybook version of reality. It's really, really cool. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog. New
访问 ShipStation.com，输入促销代码 smartless。包含畅销书、新书和独家原创内容的丰富内容，让你更贴近能够改变你生活的声音。你会找到激励你的声音、舒缓的声音、启发你的故事以及一路上鼓励你的个性人物。你知道我最近查看了什么吗？我查看了一个叫做《侥幸》（Fluke）的东西。运气、混乱以及为什么我们所做的一切都很重要。它叫《侥幸》。真的很酷。它是社会科学家布赖恩·克劳斯（Brian Kloss）写的。他做的事情是，深入探讨了随机运气的现象以及它所能散播的混乱，直指大多数人对现实整洁、井井有条的故事书式的版本。真的，非常酷。作为 Audible 会员，你可以从整个目录中选择一个月的标题来永久保留。新
members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Be sure to visit our URL so they know we sent you audible.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from HelloFresh. Whether your resolution is to save money, eat better or stress less,
会员可以免费试用 Audible 30 天。访问 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500。也就是 audible.com/smartless 或发送短信 smartless 到 500-500，免费试用 Audible 30 天。请务必访问我们的网址，让他们知道是我们介绍你去的 audible.com/smartless。SmartLess 获得 HelloFresh 的支持。无论你的新年决心是省钱、吃得更好还是减少压力，
HelloFresh is here to help you do all three. Say hello to your most delicious year yet with fresh ingredients and chefcrafted recipes at a price you'll like delivered right to your door. Each HelloFresh box is packed with farm fresh ingredients and everything arrives pre-portioned right to your doorstep for less hassle and less wasted food. So you're resolved to actually sit down and eat dinner around the table,
HelloFresh 都在这里帮助你实现这三点。用新鲜的食材和主厨精心制作的食谱，以你喜欢的价格直接送到你家门口，迎接你最美味的一年。每个 HelloFresh 盒子里都装满了农场新鲜的食材，所有东西都预先分配好直接送到你家门口，减少麻烦，减少食物浪费。所以你决心真正坐下来围坐在餐桌旁吃晚餐，
but what do you do about those nights when your schedule is packed? Turn to HelloFresh's lineup of quick and easy meals, including their 15 minute recipes designed to help minimize mealtime stress. So you know what I love? I love the rapid stir-fry beef. You know why?
但是当你的日程排得满满的时，那些夜晚该怎么办呢？转向 HelloFresh 的快捷简便餐点系列，包括他们的 15 分钟食谱，旨在帮助尽量减少用餐时间的压力。所以你知道我喜欢什么吗？我喜欢快炒牛肉。你知道为什么吗？
It's rapid like me and it's a little spicy like me. Hello, HelloFresh. Go to HelloFresh.com slash SmartLessFree and use code SmartLessFree for free breakfast for life. One breakfast item per box while subscription is active. Get free breakfast for life and support the show while you're at it. Just go to HelloFresh.com slash SmartLessFree
它和我一样快，而且和我一样有点辣。你好，HelloFresh。前往 HelloFresh.com/SmartLessFree 并使用代码 SmartLessFree 即可享受终身免费早餐。订阅有效期间，每盒可获得一份早餐单品。享受终身免费早餐，顺便支持节目。只需前往 HelloFresh.com/SmartLessFree
with code SmartLessFree. HelloFresh, America's number one meal kit. And now back to the show. One of our friends gave us a good tip, they said, because someone will ask you, hey, next month, would you mind coming over to my place and helping me out with such and such? You might say, sure, yeah, because it's a month away.
并使用代码 SmartLessFree。HelloFresh，美国排名第一的餐包。现在回到节目中。我们的一个朋友给了我们一个好建议，他们说，因为有人会问你，“嘿，下个月，你介意来我家帮我处理某某事情吗？”你可能会说，“当然，行啊”，因为那是一个月之后的事。
And then the day comes, and you're like, oh, I can't believe I said yes to that. This person said, here's what you do. If you have to imagine that it's for tomorrow, if you don't wanna do something tomorrow, That's your answer. Say no today. You just imagine that it's tomorrow.
然后到了那一天，你会想，“天哪，我怎么会答应这件事。”这个人说，你可以这样做。如果你必须想象这是发生在明天，如果你明天不想做某事，那就是你的答案。今天就拒绝。你只要想象这是明天。
If you don't wanna do it tomorrow, then go ahead and say no today. Yeah, yeah. And you're right, you replace it with tomorrow. It's kind of a good, I wanna ask you, this is gonna be sort of, I'm veering way off topic, but it's gonna ask you to do something in a few months and just pretend it's not.
如果你明天不想做，那就直接在今天说不。对，对。你说得对，你把它替换成了明天。这倒是个好主意，我想问你，这将会是，我会扯得有点远，但我要请你在几个月后做一件事，就假装它不是。
I'm just gonna say no. I'm just, no, okay. Where's Lizzie? Okay, it's a bag with 30 million euros in it, but I guess no. No, I was gonna ask you about, I love Madrid, I've been there a few times, I think it's really such a phenomenal city,
我只会说不。我只会，不，好吧。莉兹在哪里？好吧，这是一个装着3000万欧元的包，但我想还是算了吧。不，我要问你关于，我喜欢马德里，我去过那里好几次，我觉得它真的是一个非常非凡的城市，
and I really love Spain. And one of my great nights that I had in Madrid was with an old friend of mine who lives there, who's lived there for 20, 25 years, different business, finance, good guy to know. But he took me out, we went for drinks, then we went to an Atletico Madrid game, and then we went for dinner.
我真的很喜欢西班牙。我在马德里度过的美好夜晚之一，是和我的一位老朋友在一起，他住在那里，在那里住了20、25年了，做着不同的生意，金融业，是个值得结交的好人。但他带我出去，我们去喝了酒，然后去看了一场马德里竞技的比赛，接着去吃晚饭。
It was a Sunday night, and we sat down for dinner at about 11 p.m. Oh God, I'm out. And it was just starting to fill up. In the families, it was that very famous restaurant where everybody goes, I forget what it's called, but it's a very sort of fancy. And it was like, and I know that like, I don't know if the prince or the king still goes there,
那是星期天晚上，我们大约在晚上11点坐下来吃晚饭。哦天哪，我可吃不消。而那时才刚刚开始坐满。那些家庭，那是那个非常著名的餐厅，每个人都去，我忘了它叫什么名字，但它非常的高档。就像是，而且我知道，我不知道王子或国王现在是否还在那里去，
but he used to. It was like one of the, and the families would come in, 10 people in the family, the kids, everybody. I left at one o'clock, I said an early flight the next day and I'm like, I can't believe how. Why is that? Why is it always so late? Like it just sounds like a bunch of acid refluxed that in early flight the next day and I'm like, I can't believe how. Why is that? Why is it always so late?
但他们以前去过。就像是其中一个，然后那些家庭会进来，一个家庭10口人，孩子们，所有人。我一点钟离开的，我第二天还要赶早班飞机，我心想，我真不敢相信怎么会这样。为什么会这样？为什么总是这么晚？听起来就像是一群胃酸倒流
Like it just sounds like a bunch of acid reflux. Yeah. That was my schedule before, before having a family. You know, it was like normal to go to dinner at 10 with your friends or with family. But not, I mean, schools in Spain start like early, like here, like around 8.30 or 8.
我第二天还要赶早班飞机，我心想，我真不敢相信怎么会这样。为什么会这样？为什么总是这么晚？听起来就像是一群胃酸倒流。对。那是我的时间表，在，在拥有家庭之前。你知道的，晚上10点和朋友或家人一起去吃晚餐是很正常的。但现在不了，我的意思是，西班牙的学校开始得很早，就像这里一样，大约8点半或8点。
And you can have that schedule. Maybe sometimes in the weekend, but that's more for single people. Is Spain the, like the other, I've never been to Spain and I wanna go really bad. Maybe you've never been. I wanna go. No, is it kinda like, is that the country
你不可能保持那样的作息。也许周末偶尔可以，但那更多是单身人士的事。西班牙是那种，就像其他地方一样，我从来没去过西班牙，但我非常想去。也许你从来没去过。我想去。不，它是那种，是那个直到晚上10点或11点天才黑的国家
or the side of the world that doesn't get dark until like 10 or 11 at night or something like that? No, you gotta go north all the time. In the summer, we have light until 10. No way. In the summer, we do. But then further north you go, Sean. Beautiful.
或者类似的地方吗？不，你得一直往北走。夏天的时候，我们的天黑得很晚，直到10点。不会吧。夏天确实如此。但越往北走，肖恩。太美了。
The lighter it stays later. This is so, I'm so sorry. Yeah, the Delpy, we're sorry. This is a little bit of a charity hire. No, no, no. Yeah, he wanted to get into radio. He just wants to experience the light of Madrid in the summer. Yeah, so Penelope, now here you are, you're here in America and you're doing all this stuff for Ferrari,
天黑得就越晚。真是，我太抱歉了。是的，德尔皮，我们很抱歉。这有点像是慈善雇佣。不，不，不。是的，他想进入广播界。他只是想体验一下夏天马德里的阳光。对，所以佩内洛普，现在你在这里，你在美国，你在为《法拉利》做所有这些宣传，
which is, first of all, Michael Mann, of course, one of the all-time great directors. Yeah. just one of the all time great directors. But you're here, you're in America and you're doing all the stuff that goes with that. Yeah, this is what I love. The press tour, which includes talking to us, I imagine. But how, what is that like for you? Like how do you sort of gear up for that with your life and everything that's going on with the kids
这部电影，首先，迈克尔·曼，当然，是有史以来最伟大的导演之一。对。简直是有史以来最伟大的导演之一。但你在这里，你在美国，你在做所有随之而来的事情。对，这就是我所热爱的。新闻巡回宣传，其中包括跟我们对话，我想象是这样的。但是，那对你来说是怎样的？你如何调整自己的生活来应对这一切，以及孩子们身上发生的所有事情，
and you gotta go like, all right, I gotta go do all the junkets. I got it, yeah, I got it. Do you like that stuff or is it okay? As you know, it's part of it. And I just do like very short trips, like went to New York for one day for the Gotham Awards and then back home and then London one day and a half
然后你必须说，好吧，我得去跑通告了。我懂了， yeah，我懂了。你喜欢那些事情吗，还是觉得还好？如你所知，这也是其中的一部分。我只是做非常短途的旅行，比如去纽约待一天参加哥谭奖，然后回家，接着去伦敦待一天半
back home. Now we're here for a couple of days. I rather do it like this, you know, than putting together a long trip. Ideally, would you do one job a year or two jobs a year? Do you try to keep? That changed a lot. I used to do like four movies per year
然后回家。现在我们在这里呆几天。我宁愿这样安排，你知道的，也不愿把行程安排得很长。理想情况下，你一年会做一份工作还是两份工作？你试着保持……这改变很大。我以前每年拍四部电影
and travel nonstop. And now I do like one per year and they're not too long. And what I can do one in Madrid while the school is happening, I maybe would do that one and one in the summer so we can travel all together. And this is like the, I feel very privileged and very lucky to be able to do it that way
并且不停地旅行。现在我大概一年拍一部，而且它们不会太长。当我可以趁着学校上学期间在马德里拍一部时，我可能会拍那一部，然后在夏天再拍一部，这样我们就可以全家一起旅行。我觉得这就像是，能够以这种方式做事，我感到非常荣幸和非常幸运，
because I feel like all of those years working so hard have given me the opportunity to be able to choose what I want to do now and be a little bit like the owner, more or less of my own schedule. Even if you know how things always change, if they tell you you're gonna start in March, probably you're gonna start a month later. But even like counting with that
因为我觉得所有那些努力工作的岁月给了我机会，让我能够选择我现在想做什么，并且多多少少成为我自己时间表的主人。尽管你知道事情总是会发生变化，如果他们告诉你三月份开拍，你可能一个月后才会开拍。但即使把这计算在内
and knowing that that will always be the nature of our profession. Feeling like I kind of own a big part of my time is such a blessing. Yeah. Such a blessing because like I told you before, my priority is raising my children. So, and I feel so lucky that I can combine that with my work. Yeah, it's so cool to be able to shift that perspective from when you're younger and you're like you were saying,
而且深知这始终会是我们这个职业的本质。感觉自己能掌控很大一部分时间，真是一种巨大的福气。是的。真是巨大的福气，因为就像我之前对你说的，我的首要任务是抚养我的孩子们。所以，能把这一点和我的工作结合起来，我感到非常幸运。是的，能够改变那种心态真是太酷了，就像你年轻时，正如你刚才所说的，
like you're trying to make a mark, you're trying to do as much stuff as you can. You want to work with directors, you want to work on different projects. And then you get older and you're like, yeah, that stuff's not as important to me anymore. I mean, it's a luxury, obviously, but... Yeah, it is, it is.
就像你试图崭露头角，试图尽你所能做尽可能多的事情。你想和导演合作，你想参与不同的项目。然后你年纪大了，就会觉得，是的，那些东西对我来说已经没那么重要了。我的意思是，这显然是一种奢侈，但是……是的，确实是，确实是。
I mean, I don't take it for granted. And I also still love so much, like preparing a character, the research process, and being on the set, and the creativity, and how that makes me feel like searching for answers. And I still feel like the little girl that was watching the Betamax. Yeah. What was your first Hollywood film? What was your first big? It was Stephen Frears, a movie called High Low Country,
我的意思是，我不会把这视为理所当然。而且我也依然非常热爱，比如准备一个角色、搜集资料的过程，以及在片场的感觉、创造力，还有那种感觉如何让我像是在寻找答案。我依然觉得自己就像那个看着Betamax录像带的小女孩。是的。你的第一部好莱坞电影是什么？你的第一部大制作是什么？是斯蒂芬·弗雷斯执导的一部名叫《一路响勒》的电影，
and I was obsessed with him because of the grifters and Dangerously A Song. So that was also a phone call that made me so happy. Can I ask you a dorky actor question? Because you're such a great actor. You're very... I'm new question, because you're such a great actor. You're very... You too, thank you so much. No, no, you really are.
我对他崇拜得五体投地，因为看过《骗网悍将》和《危险关系》。所以这也是一个让我感到无比快乐的电话。我能问一个极客演员的问题吗？因为你是个如此优秀的演员。你非常……我是个新问题，因为你是个如此优秀的演员。你非常……你也是，非常感谢。不，不，你真的是。
There's, I find myself when I watch you play a character, I'm leaning in, I'm trying to read your mind. You're not, it's great. You don't help the audience. You're very internal and that's my favorite kind. But I think sometimes that it would be hard for me to manage that kind of subtlety with an accent. I wonder if I would be, is it easier for you
我发现自己在看你扮演角色时，会忍不住向前倾身，试图读懂你的心思。你不会，这太棒了。你不会刻意迎合观众。你非常内敛，而这正是我最喜欢的类型。但我有时会觉得，要用一种外语口音来驾驭这种微妙感对我来说会很难。我想知道，对我而言是不是更容易……
when you're playing a character that's speaking Spanish versus English because oftentimes the difference between a good performance and a bad performance will be in the way in which lines are said, in the meter, and what like you can say, I love you a million different ways, and an accent can change what an intention sounds like. I love you, I love you, I love you.
当你扮演一个说西班牙语而不是英语的角色时，因为通常好表演和坏表演的区别就在于台词的表达方式、节奏，以及你可以说，我有一百万种不同的方式说“我爱你”，而口音可以改变一种意图听起来的感觉。我爱你，我爱你，我爱你。
And oftentimes an accent is that, it changes. We're gonna go a different way. The rhythm of something Do you have to manage that at all? Is it do you even think about it? So I think about it a lot because I I feel very lucky that I'm able to do movies in four languages and a lot of different accents For example with Spanish language a lot of different accents and I feel like is sometimes I don't want to call it a disadvantage to have an accent because at the end of the day for me in my career it has given me more advantages
通常口音就是这样，它会改变。我们要走一条不同的路。某种节奏，你完全不需要去驾驭这些吗？你甚至都不会去想它吗？所以我经常会去想，因为我感到非常幸运，自己能够用四种语言和许多不同的口音拍电影。比如西班牙语，有很多不同的口音，我觉得有时候——我不想把有口音称为一种劣势，因为归根结底，对我的职业生涯来说，它带给我的优势
than the opposite because it has opened so many doors to be able to play so many different nationalities And I don't know that I could now get to play a character that has English as her first language. Maybe someday we could get to that. But would I change that but not being able to play an Italian or a French or all the characters that I can play in English that can be from so many nationalities, but like I said, maybe English is not their first language. When I'm working in Spanish, of course, it's going to be like a freedom that you're not going to have when you are working in a different language, but it's not always that way because sometimes when I'm working with a different language or accent, I don't hear myself, I don't recognize
比劣势要多得多，因为它为我打开了那么多扇大门，让我能够扮演那么多不同的国籍。我不知道我现在是否还能有机会扮演一个以英语为母语的角色。也许有一天我们能做到这一点。但是，如果为了能扮演意大利人、法国人，或者所有那些我能用英语扮演、来自许多不同国籍但就像我说的英语可能不是他们的母语的角色，而要我去改变这一切……当我说西班牙语时，当然，那会有一种你用另一种语言工作时所没有的自由，但并不总是这样，因为有时当我使用不同的语言或口音工作时，我听不到自己，我认不出
myself and that already gives me a space of distance between myself to create somebody new that actually is very helpful for me. So I mean I keep working with, I'm always with a dialect coach in my life. I've, lately I work with Tim Monic, who is incredible. I feel like I've heard of him. And I've had so many teachers in, for all different languages and accents or go to the place and spend time there. And you feel like you have as much control
我自己，而这已经为我提供了一个与自我保持距离的空间，去创造一个实际上对我非常有帮助的全新人物。所以我的意思是，我一直在跟方言教练合作，我的生活中总是有方言教练相伴。我最近跟蒂姆·莫尼克合作过，他太不可思议了。我觉得我听说过他。而且我有过那么多的老师，教我各种不同的语言和口音，或者去那个地方并花时间待在那里。你觉得自己是否有足够的掌控力
over your intention when you're reading a line, even though you might be working with an accent, versus the kind of control you have when you're working in Spanish. You feel like it's equal enough? I feel like if I put a lot, a lot of time into it, so that I get to a place where I don't have to be thinking about it, I will have the advantages of having that distance between myself and the way that character speaks and not recognizing myself when I speak. And I enjoy that very much. But for example, I'm making a movie in the spring in English and I start to work now in January
来把握念台词时的意图，尽管你可能带着口音工作，与你在用西班牙语工作时所拥有的掌控力相比？你觉得它们足够对等吗？我觉得如果我投入大量、大量的时间，直到我达到一个不需要再去思考它的地步，我就会获得那种优势，也就是在自我与那个角色的说话方式之间保持距离，并且在我说话时认不出我自己。我非常享受这一点。但例如，我将在春天用英语拍一部电影，我现在1月份就开始准备了，
and it's gonna be like every day, putting many hours into it, so that I don't have to be thinking about it when I'm there, so you just can, so it becomes part of you. And that character would have an American accent or a Spanish accent? No.
这将是一天天地投入大量的小时去练习，这样当我到片场时就不用再去想它了，你只需要……这样它就成了你的一部分。那个角色会带有美国口音还是西班牙口音？不。
It will have a Spanish accent, but we want it to be as always as clear as possible. And just so there's no gap there, so that it's much more immediate is what you're saying. Yeah, but the gap that is the accent or acting in another language sometimes helps so much to create that distance and... ...allows you to enter a different person.
她会有西班牙口音，但我们希望它能像往常一样尽可能清晰。为了确保中间没有任何隔阂，让它更加直接，你是这个意思吗？是的，但是作为口音或用另一种语言表演的那种隔阂，有时对创造这种距离感有巨大帮助，并且…………能让你融入另一个人。
Can I ask you, when you won, I think it was 2008 maybe, when you won Academy Award for Vicki Christina, right? Is that 2008, something like that? I think it was 2008. Maybe 2009, something like that for Vicki Christina, Barcelona. When you won, because this is always like a sort of a trippy thing, it's kind of like you win the great Academy Award.
我能问你吗，当你赢得，我想大概是2008年吧，当你凭借《午夜巴塞罗那》赢得奥斯卡奖的时候，对吧？是2008年左右吗？我想是2008年。也许是2009年左右，凭借《午夜巴塞罗那》。当你获奖时，因为这总是像是一种很奇幻的事情，就好像你赢得了伟大的奥斯卡奖。
Did you feel that kind of, was it euphoric in the moment? Was it let down? Did it change anything or did you go, or was it, you know, what was that sort of feeling? Was the moment as you imagined it? Yeah, yeah. Wow, it was the first one of the night. So I was happy about that because my heart was going so fast.
你当时有那种感觉吗，那一刻是极度狂喜吗？是感到失落吗？它改变了什么，还是你觉得，或者说，你知道，那是怎样一种感觉？那一刻跟你想象的一样吗？对，对。哇，那是当晚宣布的第一个奖项。所以我对此很高兴，因为我的心跳得太快了。
I don't know how I could have gone through hours of that, but it was incredible to be able to hug my mother there. I was sad my father wasn't there because they were not together as a couple. So they would take turns. And he came to some awards, he came to others and all their family and friends were there and I just, the thing is that I only remember like 30% of it because the adrenaline was so high and I remember like right after winning calling my
我不知道自己怎么能熬过那之后的几个小时，但能在那里拥抱我的母亲真是太不可思议了。我很遗憾我父亲不在那里，因为他们作为夫妻已经分开了。所以他们会轮流出席。他去过一些颁奖典礼，也去过另一些，所有的家人和朋友都在那里，我只是……问题在于我只记得大约30%的内容，因为肾上腺素飙升得太厉害了，我只记得获奖后不久给我的
father and calling Pedro and I remember- Pedro was, oh, this girl will not leave me alone. Exactly. And I remember going after the ceremony, we went to In-N-Out. Of course, with the gown and all. And then we went to Gaius Sirius House, who is a very good friend of mine. And I'm sure you've been in that party.
父亲打电话，给佩德罗打电话，我还记得——佩德罗当时说，哦，这姑娘真是阴魂不散。没错。我还记得典礼结束后，我们去了In-N-Out汉堡店。当然，还穿着礼服什么的。然后我们去了盖伊·西里斯的家，他是我非常好的朋友。我敢肯定你也去过那个派对。
I walked in and I looked to my left and in a sofa together. There was Jack Nicholson, Scorsese, Harvey K. Tell, Robert De Niro, Al Pacino, and I was like, oh, can't handle that. And I was like, the other way, I was like, I got so nervous. That image was like, oh, I should have taken a picture of that image, all of them together.
我走进去，往左一看，在一张沙发上坐在一起的有杰克·尼科尔森、斯科塞斯、哈维·凯特尔、罗伯特·德尼罗、阿尔·帕西诺，当时我想，哦，这可招架不住。于是我想，走另一边，我当时紧张得要命。那个画面就像是，哦，我真应该把那个画面拍下来，他们所有人聚在一起。
Guy can pack a house. Yeah. That, I was gonna ask you a bit ago, but that's a perfect segue. You know, you said you lived here for 15 years, but what are some of the, and then, but when you come visit, what are the some of the things you look forward to?
这家伙能聚齐一屋子大咖。是的。那个，我刚才就想问你，但这真是一个完美的过渡。你知道，你刚才说你在这里住了15年，但是其中有些什么，然后，当你回来探访时，有哪些是你最期待的事情？
Eating like in and out, or seeing or experiencing? Like do you miss anything that you get excited about here? I have a group of friends that we get together and we play wolves, wolves and villagers. Do you know the game, right? Of course, of course. And I'm sure you know some of the players.
像吃In-N-Out，还是看什么或体验什么？比如你有什么特别兴奋想念的东西吗？我有一群朋友，我们会聚在一起玩“狼人杀”，狼人和村民。你知道这个游戏吧？当然，当然。而且我确信你也认识其中一些玩家。
And oh my God, and you know everyone ends up like so angry with each other for weeks because you just have to lie and betray other people in this game. And it's a really good game for actors. And it's one of the things that I try to do when I come back to LA, like get together with the Wolf players that I have here.
天哪，你知道每个人最后都会因为这个游戏里你必须撒谎和背叛别人而对彼此生气好几个星期。这确实是一个非常适合演员的游戏。这也是我每次回到洛杉矶时尽量想做的事情之一，就是跟我在这里的“狼人”玩家们聚在一起。
And we play a lot in Spain also. You can play it on Zoom too. Have you ever played it on Zoom? No, no. Yeah, you can play it on Zoom. Interesting. Yeah, you can do it on, I think over COVID there was a lot of mafia on Zoom. Interesting.
我们在西班牙也经常玩。你也可以在Zoom上玩。你曾经在Zoom上玩过吗？没有，没有。对，你可以在Zoom上玩。有趣。是的，你可以通过，我想在疫情期间有很多在Zoom上玩的黑手党游戏。有趣。
Really? I have a team of players in Madrid, like many friends that are obsessed with the game like I am. And then other team of players here. There's a show based on it Penelope called Traders. And it's based on that. From the UK. From the UK version and American version and Australian version.
真的吗？我在马德里有一支玩家团队，有很多像我一样对这个游戏着迷的朋友。然后这里还有另一支玩家团队。佩内洛普，有一个根据它改编的节目叫《叛徒》。就是根据那个改编的。来自英国的。来自英国版、美国版和澳大利亚版。
And now a friend of mine did a Spanish version of the show. Oh really? Sergio Peris Mencheta. It's interesting. What's something that people don't know that you do, like a sort of guilty pleasure or something that you, like do you like watch Bad Reality TV? This is, I feel like Jason,
现在我的一位朋友制作了该节目的西班牙版。哦真的吗？塞尔吉奥·佩里斯-门切塔。这很有趣。有什么是人们不知道你会做的，比如某种罪恶的快感，或者你喜欢的事情，比如你看糟糕的真人秀吗？我觉得杰森，
I'm getting into your territory with this question. We love this question. We love this question. Like what do you do? Do you, are you secretly a golfer? Do you play tennis? Do you have some obsessions? I don't know.
我这个问题好像踩到你的地盘了。我们很喜欢这个问题。我们很喜欢这个问题。比如你平时都做什么？你，难道你私底下是个高尔夫球手？你打网球吗？你有什么狂热的爱好吗？我不知道。
You like to doodle. Well, I love a good massage, I have to say. Oh my God. Wow. I would have a massage every day. That's one of the best treats that you do. How I would like to, every single day. Do you get a massage once a week?
你喜欢涂鸦。好吧，我必须说，我非常喜欢做个好按摩。天哪。哇。我真想每天都按摩。那是你享受的最好犒劳之一。我有多想每天都按一次。你每周按摩一次吗？
No, but I don't know. Once a month. Maybe once a month, once a month. But I love it. I hurt my back in the shower, actually, the other day. Just doing? Yeah, just like trying to wash my feet, just reaching down to visit, and out it goes.
不，但我不清楚。一个月一次吧。也许一个月一次，一个月一次。但我真的很喜欢。其实前几天我在淋浴时把背给扭了。就只是在做……？对，就是试图洗脚，弯腰去够的时候，背就闪了。
So I got a massage last night. It was so deep and so painful. I hurt more today than I did yesterday. But it's all different. It's all, I'm just sore from, so sometimes it can be a little too hard. Yes, Penelope? I don't know.
所以我昨晚去按摩了。手法太深太痛了。我今天比昨天更疼了。但完全不一样。完全是，我只是酸痛而已，所以有时候力度可能会有点太大。是的，佩内洛普？我不知道。
It's one of my, I don't know, what can you call it? It's a hobby. What can you call it? It's a passion. It's a passion. It's a treat. It's a treat. And I love knitting.
这是我的一个，我不知道，这该叫什么？这是一种爱好。这该叫什么？这是一种激情。这是一种激情。这是一种犒劳。这是一种犒劳。而且我非常喜欢织毛衣。
Oh, you do? Oh, you do. Yeah, starting to do that with my daughter because my grandmother taught me how to do that and sewing and I love cooking because with my job it's not that I can cook every day but it's something that I really like and I don't have a lot of, actually like a lot of social life and I don't really go out, I don't drink. I have strange hobbies also. Or like?
哦，是吗？哦，你会啊。是的，开始和我女儿一起织，因为我外祖母教过我怎么织毛衣和缝纫，而且我非常喜欢烹饪，因为由于我的工作，我并不是每天都能做饭，但这是我真的很喜欢的一件事，而且我其实没有太多的……实际上有很多社交活动，我也不怎么出门，我不喝酒。我还有一些奇怪的爱好。或者像？
I don't know why I always end up talking about this in interviews, but I love reading about medicine. I do too. I do too. Why are you hypercontact? Yes, I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed.
我不知道为什么我总是在采访中聊起这个，但我喜欢阅读医学方面的东西。我也是。我也是。为什么你这么超级关注？是的，我很着迷。我很着迷。我很着迷。
I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. I'm obsessed. That's true. You do, I love when I find somebody that can discuss endocrine system. I'm like, oh, best friend. Sean is on a VIP program. This is not a joke at Cedars because he's so obsessed with his own, right? Am I, I'm not, he has his own entrance. Yeah.
我很着迷。我很着迷。我很着迷。这倒不假。你确实……我最喜欢找到能跟我讨论内分泌系统的人。我就会觉得，哦，最佳好友。肖恩在西达斯西奈医院有VIP项目。这不是开玩笑的，因为肖恩对自己的……对吧？我是吗？我不是，他有专属入口。是的。
Yeah. Well, you and I best friends. Yes, I mean, I'm obsessed. But do you both, do you both worry about mortality? his own entrance. Yeah. Yeah. You and I best friends. Yes. I'm obsessed. But do you both worry about mortality? Do you feel like it's... It's not about mortality.
是的。好吧，你和我绝对是好朋友。是的，我的意思是，我很着迷。但你们俩，你们俩都担心生老病死吗？他有专属入口。是的。是的。你和我绝对是好朋友。是的。我很着迷。但你们俩都担心生老病死吗？你觉得这是……这不是关于死亡。
It's about suffering. Yes. It's not about mortality. It's about suffering. I don't want to catch it. Tell me how did you get it? How do I avoid it? You know, all that.
这是关于痛苦。是的。这不是关于死亡。这是关于痛苦。我可不想染上它。告诉我你是怎么得的？我该怎么避开它？你知道，诸如此类。
Yes, yes, yes. Were you both very nervous about COVID when COVID was around? Were you both nervous about that? I was more nervous for other people, for older or for children. Obviously, we didn't know what was gonna happen and I was worried for my mom. Did everybody get COVID?
是的，是的，是的。新冠疫情期间，你们俩对新冠病毒都非常紧张吗？你们俩对此都很紧张吗？我更多的是为其他人感到紧张，比如老年人或儿童。显然，我们不知道会发生什么，我很为我妈妈担心。所有人都感染过新冠吗？
I did, I did go COVID. Sean, did you get it? You still haven't had it, right, Will? I've never had it, no. Oh my God. But Penelope, I'm go COVID. Sean, did you get it? You still haven't had it, right? Well, I've never had it, no. Oh my God. But Penelope, I'm more worried about like, like if I, if like my stomach hurts or like my eye hurt, I'm like, oh my God, I have cancer, I'm gonna die
我得过，我确实得过新冠。肖恩，你得过吗？你到现在还没得过吧，威尔？我从来没得过，没有。天哪。但是佩内洛普，我更担心的是，比如，如果我的胃疼或者眼睛疼，我就会想，天哪，我得癌症了，我要死了
or like whatever, I go from zero to a hundred and then I have to read all about it and like. But you, why should be you scared? You've got an extra eye, don't you? The thing is that you have to know where to read it. And when you do this, you end up knowing where to go. It's not like, doesn't it happen to you? Like if you go to the doctor with the right questions
或者诸如此类，我总是小题大做，然后我不得不阅读所有相关的资料，比如。但你，你为什么要害怕？你不是多长了一只眼睛吗？关键是，你必须知道在哪里阅读。当你这样做时，你最终就会知道该去哪里看。难道不是吗？难道你不会这样吗？如果你带着正确的问题去看医生，
and they tell you, you're not one of those that is reading everything on internet. And it's like, what depends if you go to the right places, you actually can come here with the right questions. It doesn't mean you go to the doctor with the answers, but you go with the right questions and sometimes they don't like that. That's right. That's right.
他们会告诉你，你可不是那种在互联网上什么都读的人。而且这取决于如果你去对了地方，你实际上可以带着正确的问题去。这并不意味着你带着答案去看医生，但你是带着正确问题去的，有时他们不喜欢这样。没错。没错。
My doctor is like, yeah, look it up online. He always says that. Does he really? It sounds pretty lazy. If you're being like, or take a picture and text it to me. That's what he says. Well, listen, Penelope, we have taken up way too much of your time. It's such an honor having you here and to join us.
我的医生总是说，行吧，自己在网上查查。他总是这么说。他真的会这样吗？听起来挺懒的。如果你一直在说，或者拍张照片发短信给我。他就是这么说的。好吧，听着，佩内洛普，我们占用了你太多时间了。非常荣幸你能来到这里并加入我们。
Yeah, it's so nice of you to join us. I love this. You said earlier to me that I need to experience the light of Madrid and I think I just did. Oh, no, I had so much fun talking to you right here. I feel it's too short. You shined your light on us. It is too short. I had so much fun in this conversation right here. I feel it's too short. You shine your light on us. It is too short. I had so much fun in this conversation.
是的，你能加入我们真是太好了。我太喜欢了。你刚才对我说我需要体验马德里的阳光，我想我刚刚体验到了。哦，不，我和你在这里聊天玩得太开心了。我觉得时间太短了。你把光芒照耀在我们身上。时间太短了。我在这次谈话中玩得太开心了。我觉得时间太短了。你把光芒照耀在我们身上。时间太短了。我在这次谈话中玩得太开心了。
We'll continue at a Madrid. Next time we're down to Madrid, we're gonna look you up. We're gonna have an 11 PM dinner on a Sunday night. You're gonna cook for us. Yes, I will if you want. Yes. We'll do it. Well listen, continued success really.
我们在马德里继续聊。下次我们去马德里时，我们会去找你的。我们在周日晚上11点吃个晚餐。你要给我们做饭。好的，如果你想的话，我会的。好的。我们就这么说定了。好吧，听着，祝你事业长青。
And congratulations to your trip. Enjoy your trip, your holidays, get back to the family. And I can't wait for Ferrari. Yeah, we can't wait. Yeah, we're looking forward to that. Thank you, thank you so much. Yeah, we're such fans. Thank you.
祝你的旅行一切顺利。好好享受你的旅行和假期，回去陪伴家人吧。我等不及要看《法拉利》了。是的，我们都等不及了。是的，我们非常期待。谢谢，非常感谢。是的，我们是你的超级粉丝。谢谢。
You've been really kind, thank you so much. Thank you, Penelope. Thank you, bye. Bye-bye. Fuck, I'm fucking, look at this. Oh, look at that. You were so, Penelope was so great, you're sweating. I know, that was, I mean, gosh, right?
你真是太好了，非常感谢。谢谢你，佩内洛普。谢谢，再见。再见。靠，我真他妈的，看看这个。哦，看那个。你太……佩内洛普太棒了，你都出汗了。我知道，那真是，天哪，对吧？
Penelope Cruz. I didn't know what to do. I'm such a fan, I've never met her or anything and I didn't know what to expect. I know, me neither. And now I'm like a bigger fan. Like she's really fun and easy. I was hoping that she was gonna be as charming
佩内洛普·克鲁兹。我当时不知道该怎么办。我是她的超级粉丝，我以前从来没见过她什么的，也不知道该期待什么。我知道，我也是。现在我成了她更大的粉丝。她真的很有趣而且随和。我当时希望她能像看上去那样迷人
and as wonderful as she seems to be, right? Did she ever play that game where you watch people on talk shows and stuff like that, and you're just a fan of theirs and you feel like, like what she was saying about Pedro Almotovar, I think that's how you say it, like she could just tell, boy, if we ever met we'd really get along. I played that sometimes, I looked at people, I was like, you know what, I bet she'd be awesome. I think a lot of people do think that sometimes
而且那么棒，对吧？你有没有玩过那种游戏，就是你在脱口秀节目之类的地方看人们，你只是他们的粉丝，你会觉得，就像她刚才说的关于佩德罗·阿尔莫多瓦尔，我想他名字是这么念的，她就是能看出来，天哪，如果我们见面了，我们一定会很合得来。我有时也会玩这种游戏，我看着别人，心想，你知道吗，我打赌她一定会超棒的。我想很多人有时也会这么想
in the general public and they're like psychotic a little bit, but she's not because she's actually legitimately great. Well, you were getting a psycho vibe when you'd watch her. Not from her. I'm saying that the people, you know, there are people who watch moves and go like, I would be best friends with Jason Bateman.
在普通大众中，他们有点像有心理问题，但她不是，因为她实际上真的很棒。好吧，你刚才看她的时候有一种精神病人的感觉。不是从她那里。我的意思是，有人，你知道，有些人看电影然后说，我将成为杰森·贝特曼的生死之交。
I will go and wait for him. I will wait for him and we will be, you know what I mean? But Sean, you kind of said it like, it's a little different when we will be, you know what I mean? But Sean, you kind of said it like it's a little different when it's her, you know, she shows up and you're like, um, yeah, okay, yeah, feel free to hang out. I want to see that movie. I want to see that movie.
我要去等他。我要等他，然后我们会，你知道我的意思吗？但是肖恩，你刚才说的那种感觉有点不同，当是她的时候，你知道我的意思吗？她出现时你会觉得，嗯，好吧，是的，随时可以一起闲逛。我想看那部电影。我想看那部电影。
I know I want to see Ferrari so bad. I know me too. I love. I like Adam. I like her. I like Michael Mann and I do like cars. Cars, you know? I mean, I don't know if I'd ever be able to pull off owning one,
我知道我太想看《法拉利》了。我知道我也是。我喜欢。我喜欢亚当。我喜欢她。我喜欢迈克尔·曼，而且我确实喜欢车。车，你知道吗？我的意思是，我不知道自己是否能买得起一辆，
but I do. I do. Now you got to have a certain, you kind of got to have a certain thing to be able to own a Ferrari. Yeah. Hey, Will, you ever owned a Ferrari? Funnily enough, I have, but the point is an old one, an old one, not like a classic. No, I don't like, not like one of these douchebags who drives drives around you know, LA and one of those, you know, sure
但我确实。我确实。现在你得具备某种条件，你必须有某种特定资产才能买得起一辆法拉利。对啊。嘿，威尔，你买过法拉利吗？说实话，我买过，但重点是一辆旧的，一辆旧的，不是那种经典款。不，我不喜欢，不像那种到处招摇撞骗的混蛋，开着那种车在洛杉矶转悠，你知道的，当然。
Yeah, I've never I've never been in one. I've only seen them drive by oh Shawnee snuck it right through Smart. Lass. Smart. Lass. SmartLass is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barberco. Smart. Lass. SmartLess. If you like SmartLess, you can listen early and ad-free right now by joining Wondry Plus
是的，我从来没坐过。我只见过它们从身旁开过。哦，肖恩轻巧地切过去了。聪明的小妞。聪明的小妞。SmartLass 100%有机且由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjalf和Bennett Barberco手工制作。Smart. Lass. SmartLess. 如果你喜欢 SmartLess，现在就可以通过加入 Wondry Plus 在 Wondry App 或 Apple Podcasts 上抢先收听无广告版。Prime 会员可以在 Amazon Music 上收听无广告版。在离开之前，请在 wondry.com 上填写一份简短的调查问卷，让我们更好地了解您。Academy 是一部全新的剧本化播客，讲述了 HBO《行业》主演所扮演的 Ava Richards 的故事……学校里最令人垂涎的学术前10名，由校长亲自策划。但是在意识到自己靠自己毫无机会进入这份名单后，她勉强接受了一个秘密地下社团的邀请，该社团操纵着校园生活和学业成功。如果她向他们的意志屈服，她将拥有一切梦寐以求的东西。
in the Wondry app or on Apple Podcasts. Prime members can listen ad-free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at wondry.com. Academy is a new scripted podcast that follows Ava Richards, played by HBO's Industries, www.candry.com.au student to make the list. Bishop Gray is all coveted academic top 10, curated by the headmaster himself. But after realizing she has no chance at the list on her own, she reluctantly accepts an invitation to a secret underground society that pulls the strings on campus life and academic success. If she bends to their will, she'll have everything she's ever dreamed of.
但代价是什么？《Academy》将你带入一个残酷的私立学校世界，在这里，权力和金钱以及性在生死游戏中碰撞。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方关注《Academy》。现在加入 Wondry Plus，即可抢先无广告畅听《Academy》的所有剧集。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
But at what cost? Academy takes you into the world of a cutthroat private school where power, money, and sex collide in a game of life and death. Follow Academy on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can binge all episodes of Academy early and ad-free right now by joining Wondery Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但代价是什么呢？《学院》带你走进一个竞争残酷的私立学校，在这里，权力、金钱和性在一场生死游戏中交织碰撞。在Wondery应用或你获取播客的任何地方关注《学院》。通过加入Wondery Plus，你现在就可以抢先且无广告地畅听《学院》的所有单集。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。